[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
what is going on everyone welcome to the
saturday morning live stream we're doing
it it used to be cartoons when i was a
kid now it's vfx
so i mean i don't know what y'all
watched his kids on saturday morning but
um there's usually cartoons for me it's
good to be here it's a very very special
stream it's like a double
special stream uh we're gonna be joined
by jonathan winbush here in two seconds
uh and we're creating stuff for the
looking glass we're gonna be doing
a bunch of holographic art we're gonna
be using unreal engine five and just
experimenting with all the cool stuff
that we can create and and see through
this magical looking glass portrait box
and i'll talk about that in just a
second but first let's get down to
business uh
win bush dude what is up man
what up what up what's good hey man how
you doing
happy to be here as always you know
how's everything on your end good man
very good you know we just set up for
the stream we got all the cameras
connected we got all the mics connected
we got all of our our displays set up so
we're ready to go um
i really appreciate you joining me man
um it's been a long time coming it has
been a long time coming
yeah i know we've talked about this
since camp mograph last year so it's
definitely um you know time flies you
know we both busy you know working
putting together tutorials stuff like
that so
glad that we were finally able to align
and create something dope today yeah man
agreed so it'll be sweet like i'm just
excited to hop in here and just
experiment well we have the sandbox
today so we're just gonna have some fun
and just like mess around and create
some cool stuff for the glass
um
so
let's see um
y'all are probably wondering what the
heck is this looking glass so
let me uh they're the sponsor today's
video if you all haven't figured it out
by now um so let me let me run a little
thing for you and show you guys a little
just a little bit on what the looking
glass is and then me and wind bush we're
gonna hop in and start creating stuff
for it so back in two seconds stay
seated
is a holographic display it's called the
portrait and it's one of the three
displays made by looking glass factory
the leader in holographic solutions the
looking glass portrait shows images and
videos in true 3d to multiple people at
once without glasses and without camera
tracking it's like having a window into
another world right on your desk you can
shoot in portrait mode on your phone and
display those immediately right on the
looking glass portrait because they come
with a z depth pass built in for other
images you can run those through looking
glasses 2d to 3d conversion software and
to view your 3d art with the best
results you can use their plugin for
blender unreal engine or unity to
capture your scene from a bunch of
different angles which exports a quilt
image to be read on the glass this way
refraction and reflection will shift and
adjust based on the angle that you're
looking at the glass from super cool you
can also display your 3d viewport on the
glass making small quick adjustments
super easy so if you're trying to view
the worlds and art that you create in 3d
for real with your own eyeballs then
click the link in the description to get
40 bucks off your looking glass portrait
or if you're just curious what's
possible with the looking glass check
out their discord community in the
description below where you can download
other artists holographic art and get
inspired to create your own
all right so this thing really is crazy
like it
you know i hate to say oh you got to see
it to believe it
it's amazing in person is absolutely
incredible the fact that you have this
little box sitting by your desk
and
you can look into any 3d world you want
any 3d world you can create any picture
you want to throw in it's so cool to
look at it
and and it's pretty unbelievable
so
definitely check out that link if you
guys have a moment um and and see for
yourself also the all the stuff that um
that win bush and i create today on the
stream um i'm gonna upload all that
stuff as a little folder for you guys to
download if you already have a looking
glass so you can experience all the art
we create on the stream uh for yourself
for real uh who do we got in the chat
arturo what's up dude
yo
good to see you man
um
i was going to say too they should look
in a discord because there's a homebrew
community behind the looking glass like
someone actually put like a nintendo
emulator in there and they were playing
like super mario brothers like as a
hologram so it's not just art like
there's like there's a raspberry pi in
the right so there's a little computer
in there you could do some really really
dope stuff with this
jeez yeah it's like it's crazy because
like crazy
on their discord right they have um
whole community like you said and
everyone's putting out stuff constantly
it's a really cool way to like see what
is possible on this thing because i'm
like okay i just gotta get my art on it
that's the first thing i get my art on
it and then from there it's like
oh shoot like you can do so much more
with this thing it's interactive and
everything it's it's pretty nuts um
but uh wind bush hey man how was how was
nab
uh it was dope a lot of fun definitely
great to be in front of you know in real
life in front of other artists and the
audience and stuff like that so
it was um it just went by super fast
like it was like a week long i spoke at
the maximum booth i did like our
presentation live stream there um i did
two presentations with epic games on the
nab main stage so it was it was a lot of
fun just getting back into it doing
public talking because that's where i
feel like i have my most fun right like
you know doing stuff like this is cool
but i love interacting with the audience
and just being out there and seeing you
guys you know absolutely man it's a
whole different energy you know like
yeah even if like i know we're you know
we're talking over discord right now and
if we were together it'd be a different
it'd be a different energy you know um
yeah if the audience if it was a live
setting it'd be a different energy so
the the more
live and in person it can be i think the
better
um
but
yeah i'm excited to hop in with you here
guys we got some good people in the chat
um let's just switch over here let's get
let's get creating
nope
all righty
um so i got the looking glass set up
here you guys it's just on desktop view
right now but we'll get to it we'll
start making some stuff for it
yes
and i actually i have mine sitting
beside me here if you can see it inside
the camera i'll be lifting it up you
know as i'm working on stuff in here but
yeah it's
let's get it started you ready to roll
let's do it yeah yeah um
what you got you got that's a full-on
unreal scene huh
yeah so
like i like experimenting right so i
know we had talked about you know we're
going to create stuff on the fly but
with like on my youtube channel right
like i've done a couple looking glass
tutorials already like i made an
interactive game with the xbox
controller i did um i remade people's 28
million dollar hologram inside the
looking glass but that was all in unreal
engine 4 right and so with unreal engine
5 since it's properly out now it came
out a few weeks ago we're on version
5.01 i wanted to do some experimenting
with it first before i started creating
something from scratch and so the scene
that i have right here was actually a
charity drop that we did for children of
ukraine a couple of weeks ago um put
together by perry cooper where i can
actually play this back so let me see
yeah so if i play it i actually did like
a fluid sim inside a cinema 4d brought
that into unreal engine and you know
just like i made a kid's playroom and
everything everything's running in real
time in unreal engine 5. so i thought
since i already have this scene set up
it would be dope to see if i could just
bring already made stuff into the
looking glasses so i wanted to do that
live here on the stream i haven't tested
this out yet but that's part of the fun
of it right so yup
absolutely that's a really nice thing to
rock it out sweet ah thank you man i
appreciate it yeah
um
so yeah do you wanna you wanna just hop
in you wanna show them how it's done um
yeah yeah so let me
zoom back out here
and let me actually
add my camera like so
so this is my full scene right here
right like the background is actually
just the shot hdr i have a lot of mega
skin stuff in here i have some graffiti
and stuff on the table so pretty simple
scene i think these objects were built
with nanite if i remember right yeah but
to get started and i might need your
assistance on this part with the night
stuff but
let me bring in the hololens camera so i
believe it's under our classes right
yeah if you go to earth
yeah on the left side you bring in the
hollow
blue box
there we go holo play capture right here
i'm gonna come down to my lower right
hand side let's drag this up i'd like to
zero it out just so it's in the center
here like so uh eight win bush real
quick are you able to share your screen
with me or
with that let's see soto could he could
he screen share his his uh scene or no
i am
but my um
my discord is on my ipad
so
i got you here yeah i got you
okay perfect
yeah cool
so
i have my hololens camera or not hollow
my um looking glass camera right here
i'm just gonna
position it in my scene like so
let's see
and that should be good so
i'm just going to off the cuff i'm just
going to send it over to my my looking
glass right here so this button up here
you can actually see the looking glass
logo i'm gonna click on this and
oh yeah so it actually does just show up
right inside the looking glass if you
guys can see that right there
it actually is in my my looking glass
yeah i know i got like cables all over
the place that they set up there but um
yeah i mean that's dope let me actually
hit play to see
what it looks like when we're playing on
here i'd be surprised if the frame rate
was good
yeah i mean it's decent it looks like
stop motion right definitely
yeah i found that the like the live view
is good for um kind of running running
through tests seeing how your lighting
works seeing how the frame works then
you can export out um
you know like a little animation or
something
so you can mess with everything you mess
with field of view you can mess with
basically those little white brackets
will control um
what where the focus is and what it's
looking at and by the way for all of you
guys who are like
for the very few of you who probably
have a looking glass at this point i
have links in the description for the
plugins for everything um
every even cinema 4d there's a user made
one by russ uh rust animation
rush russ etheridge i think his name is
um yeah so that's in the description as
well for c4d there's not an official one
out but there is there's a big big
community around it so
um
and
yeah i'm just gonna i'm gonna start i'm
gonna start
figuring something out uh while win bush
is doing his thing i'm gonna start
building stuff too because i got some
ideas i wanna i wanna get into
yeah so i mean this is working out
pretty well like i'm looking at it
through my looking glass right now and
yeah i mean it's gonna need a little tlc
but it's dope to see that you know it
could work right out the box like it was
pretty simple to set up you know
absolutely
um
chat what's up what's up everybody
how you guys doing
i'm actually going to
i'm going to close this out i'm going to
start this fresh scene just like you are
so let me open up
epic games launcher
yeah if anybody has any questions feel
free to ask you know
that's what this is all about yeah if
you could add us
in the chat that'll be a lot easier to
see um
that definitely helps uh papaxo i have
not tried modeling tools in unreal
um
i know was that a new thing in five win
bush
um they actually added that in 4.27 okay
but
it was like very very early and
rudimentary back then but in five they
actually with this latest update they um
they really went in on it so it's
actually usable now like before it's
just simple shapes and everything but
now yeah it's pretty um it's pretty
legit especially for like gray boxing
and stuff like that like if you're into
gray boxing you're seeing out first you
know with simple geometry just trying to
get your composite together and
everything and then you start polishing
it you know bringing in your cg models
and your kit bashing and stuff like that
is really good for that type of stuff
like back when i used to use unity
that's how i used to actually operate
like i would build up my scene in cinema
4d just like simple squares and
rectangles and triangles just really
trying to work on the composition of the
scene first then i would bring that into
unity and actually make like you know
like first person interactive levels and
stuff like that so
that was all built in the unity and it's
really cool to see that we're starting
to get in that into unreal engine now
nice yeah the the i've never heard the
gray box term i had to call it block out
but i guess i just made that up so
there's probably a more the proper term
but it's cool to hear that you do that
too
you know it's funny um
because when i was learning unreal
engine right especially being a motion
graphics artist like back then this is
like 2019 like there was no motion
graphics artist using unreal right and
so
the way that i learned it i actually
started you know watching the game
developers on twitch and interacting
with the game developers so i picked up
a lot of their terms and that was
something that they would often talk
about is gray boxing out the level and
then um building it out but yeah that's
where so if i use any type of lingo like
that it's more than likely because i've
been just talking to game developers for
the past couple of years you know trying
to figure all this stuff out
so
i think i'm going to build out a
landscape first so i'm going to open up
rope creator i'm not sure if you're
familiar with rogue creator at all
totally
oh i just cried yeah
oh no did you yeah it's gonna happen i'm
not worried
yeah world creator is legit um did they
come out with three yet are they still
on two
they came out with three but i haven't
like you know i've been like all over
the place so i haven't had a chance to
really dive into three yeah so
like i'm more familiar with um two right
now so it'll be faster for me to just
work in this but nice i definitely want
to get into three at some point i do
have it but i just haven't had a chance
to
determine at all with it
yeah you're on my screen right now yeah
i've seen you
all right cool and actually
oh i don't want to do that i'm just
going to build a scene out from scratch
i was going to try to bring in data from
like the grand canyon or something like
that but that's crazy that we could do
that i'll just bring in the grand canyon
real quick
yeah like i did that a lot for work
right like if i have to like be like
geologically accurate with the map that
i'm building out or something like that
like i'll bring in like them data from
you know like real world applications
like grand canyon or i do a lot of shows
that take place in alaska stuff like
that and so
it's like i'll bring in that real world
information and then i'll bring it into
real creator and then i could kind of
like sculpt it and really fine-tune it
from there and then i could bring in
like a
like a really accurate landscape of you
know real locations and stuff which is
it's crazy that we could do that type of
stuff these days right i mean
when i first started doing motion
graphics this stuff was just like a pipe
dream so yeah wait so where are you
pulling that from
i heard of a site you can like look at
top-down parts of the world and get a
depth map are you doing the same thing
yeah so there was a site called
terrain.party
in which um
i think it's been down for a couple of
months like i haven't been able to pull
data from it and so what i've been using
lately is this program called um
dem earth inside of cinema 4d actually i
could probably just pull it up so let me
because this is really really dope like
a lot of people like i cover it on my
youtube channel but
a lot of people still don't really know
about it and it's really good if you
want to bring in you know like terrains
from anywhere in the world like
basically all i have to do is
like give it a location that i want you
know like the grand canyon and then it
will pull in the satellite data from i
want to say like google maps or
something like that and it will build it
all out inside of cinema 4d which is
really really crazy and then from there
you can actually um texture it with you
know the different map sites like
starman or google earth or bing maps and
stuff like that so jeez it's pretty
crazy yeah it's built into c4d it's like
a plug-in of some sort
yeah so like um i have cinema 4d 25 open
right now
so if you look at my top panel i have a
little button here that says dem earth
oh snap so if i click on them earth
object
there we go so it brought in just a
generic terrain right now i'm not sure
what location this is but it's like if i
want to bring in
let's say i keep saying the grand canyon
because i just love that topography yeah
that landscape is really dope so i'm
actually just going to search grand
canyon
and it's going to give me good results
here so i got grand canyon arizona or i
could do grand canyon on the nevada side
so
i'll just hit go to arizona
holy crap and
there we go so now i have the geometry
of the grand canyon just right here
which is mine uh i wrote that down i'm
definitely getting that that is that is
the next level
i will hook you up with the developer i
talk to him often because i've been
using this plugin for years yeah and
this is
like it was a lifesaver holy crap dude
that's insane i love it i'm excited to
see what what's your idea right now what
are you going for um what are you trying
to do
so i think i might try to build a desert
scene out first like i do have this
really dope dragon that i got from the
unreal marketplace so i might try to
create like a little desert scene to put
that dragon into and see what it looks
like inside the looking glass there yeah
but
let me see
so this is
this is like all the terrain of the
grand canyon but you can see
the crevices and everything down there
that's right actually
let me amplify the height map here let's
say about like 500
but now we could really dang
and actually that looks kind of crazy so
let me bring it
to 200
and i can actually throw some terrain on
here real quick just so we can see
what it's going to look like so if i
download texture
and this will take a few moments to to
download here but this is more just for
an example to show you guys like what
kind of
terrain
textures that we could get in here and
stuff but what i'm going to do is
probably export this out
bring it into row creator make it look
more like sand dunes and stuff like that
and then bring that into unreal engine
with the terrain generator so nice nice
at least in theory that's what i'm going
to do right
it's all experiment absolutely just
coming up with this off the cuff
so i'm going to try
uh
so unreal keeps crashing when i bring in
kit bash's um
like full pack because they're beefy
packs i think it's probably because i'm
building nanite
for it i would assume so i'm just gonna
try and like pull the ones that i only
need in c4d
and i want to try and do a cool like
top-down view of some buildings
uh
inside of the looking glass and see what
that looks like so
that's what i'm gonna try and do dang
all of these would be very handy to have
in unreal i'm gonna try this one more
time
without
nanite what building pet way down kit
bash pack is that that you're using
there that's neo tokyo
oh so that's from kit bash 3d
and that's not opening for you in unreal
the fbx
when i drag the fbx in
um and i build nanite
it gets to like 11 percent crashes
yeah it's gonna say what if you don't
build it to name night because i don't
know
yeah if the
the scene is built for that i'm gonna
give it a shot those kid bashes could
that that
um particular one is kind of old yeah
it is yeah it is it is old for sure
because i know they support all that
stuff now like they have full on real
support and everything
yeah
if you look at my screen here like this
is i brought in map data from
let me see this is google terrain
so you can actually see
like where you're working at inside the
terrain there so this is all the grand
canyon national park there
um
let's see how far we get yeah so we can
get back pretty far
with this terrain here
so if you watch any shows especially um
actually i have a show out on history
channel right now it's called aztec gold
and this is how i built like all the
maps for that right there like it takes
place in the
lower southwest of america going from
mexico up through you know like
california nevada that region there and
stuff like that so yeah
yeah this is how i built the maps out
for that so that's so cool
i'm actually going to export out some
height data that i could bring into row
creator so
i'm gonna export out hype map as a png
and
i'll just leave it dude you're just like
swallowing so hard right now
i mean this is what i do like i don't
know i'm just like super
super nerd like that right so
that's awesome
that's freaking awesome yes
save this to my desktop
this might take a few moments to
download so i'm gonna just go back to
real creator and actually
start a new project here so don't want
to save a new one no
i'm just going to prep this for
bringing that data in so
i'm probably going to make like a
a 4k terrain here so i'm doing 4096 by
4096
come down to custom base shape
edit shape then i'm going to flatten my
entire terrain
like so
and then
i'm going to actually bring in that png
that i just exported out
from cinema 4d let me see if i remember
how to do this so add area
i fit terrain to size
i'm going gonna bring up my resolution
like 4k
and then what else do i need to do bring
these all the way out to the end like so
cool and let me see if my stuff actually
went to my
desktop yet
so okay yeah i have my height data here
and yeah feel free like i'm just talking
so we don't have any dead air but feel
free to oh no it's chill too we got some
background music nice um i got my stuff
imported finally
my loading just finished so i'm able to
start building some stuff out
nice
i'm gonna let this import
let me see
hopefully i don't get a crash now now
i'm saying not respond oh there we go
there we go
said that clinton jumps me there for a
minute
well we trade out because i think i'm up
and running too so yeah now i'm good it
looks like i got my data in here um
i think i'm trying to remember how to do
this so i want to
i'm gonna
raise up my height map
i know i think i did that the wrong way
so i'm gonna remove this
added area
and i'm going to make it fit
my terrain
pop it off
how's your stuff coming in you're smooth
now
i'm i'm on to the next step so that's
good
that is very good it's all in pieces and
like random pieces
um
[Music]
how did you bring it in did you just
open up the
fbi unreal project or are you just
dropped in fbx yeah let's see if i just
what's that that was huge
yeah right
i had a minor uh something just happened
there but yeah boom we're in son look at
that wow
we got all these buildings
good thing we got a limiter on this mic
um yeah i say blew my air drums out
[Laughter]
uh apologies um
yes
i gotta open up photoshop so
i had like a 16k terrain that i was
trying to bring in the world creator it
looks like i can only bring in 8k so i'm
just going to go to photoshop and
do a little make it
smaller
yeah you know how it is
oh this is ah this is nice i just want
to be on top of this build
yeah
did you see that um
did you see the stuff that people were
doing with the matrix demo you know like
the city scene that they have for the
matrix um
yeah what they call it but the unreal
demo so people were actually taking that
and putting like superman in there or
they're putting like spider-man and
stuff like that so that's what that kind
of reminded me of like a lot of crazy
stuff people been doing lately with that
totally the only thing i've seen someone
do is something like anamorphic test
that's it but
it's just i haven't done it i hadn't
opened that scene up have you opened it
yeah i tried to run it on my machine and
it was just
it was just too much like i'm on a 2080
ti right now right so i get it but i
know um matt walkman was actually
telling me he's like if i would have
kept it as an executable and then tried
to play it that
i would have had better luck trying to
run it because i was trying to run it
inside the viewport right
that thing was just
it was just chugging
just again
five frames per second on there
failed to save correctly okay that's not
good
oh no your camera oh wait wait there you
go yeah oh it's my
all right there you go
yes i got this at nab i got unroll water
bottle for my hikes that i do on the
weekend that's a water bottle dude hold
that up again they'll get up again
yeah let me see
get a hold it don't love it you can tell
a person based off their water bottle
yeah just a little bit
i will never go without water again on
my hikes like i tried to um yeah last
year i was hiking and i didn't realize
there was a heat wave going on out here
and um like i usually like the size
water that you take that's what i
usually take and um
i probably got about like four miles out
and it was like real desert area you
know like up on the hills and stuff like
that and um
yeah i almost like dehydrated like it
was just crazy you know it got up to
like 105 degrees down here and
it was insane so i'm like i'll never go
without water again you know so dude i
go like over and beyond that life juice
man um
what you ever try one of those like uh
what is it like the water packs on the
back
you know my son has that but um
yeah i've never done that like
i don't know because in my book bag when
i go hiking like i'd like to take food
you know like apples and trail mix you
know nuts and stuff like that so i like
to have a lot of room in there and then
also have like my emergency kit in case
something happens you know yeah and so i
usually just take like a ton of water
bottles um i bring some gatorade
and then i always like to bring extra
water bottles too right in case i ever
see anybody that's in distress on the
hiking trails because i've i've come
across people that have been in trouble
you know maybe they try to push
themselves too far and whatnot so
it's always good to have extra on you
just in case so
what's the sketchiest thing that's ever
happened to you
during a hike
um besides almost dying from dehydration
like that one was crazy during the
heatwave because i actually had vultures
circling above me which i got i got
pictures on my phone as proof but yeah
that was a crazy time because i'm like
damn am i really going to die out here
in the middle of these this canyon out
here so damn that was crazy and then um
there was another instance where i was
hiking out there in laguna hills
and um
i had like this truck like i was at this
campsite right because there was like a
a
bathroom site out there yeah so i'm just
sitting there at the table in um this
like this truck grows up they look like
a truck like straight out of like
baywatch like it had like the surfboard
and the buoying and stuff on the side
and this guy jumps out and he's like are
you okay
and i'm like yeah you know i'm just
hiking why what's up and they're like we
got a distress call that somebody was
hyperventilating because they forgot
their um
what's that thing called when you have
asthma it's like that little inhaler
thing that like yeah they forgot their
inhaler and they got lost out in the
hills because um i guess they're i don't
know for whatever reason they weren't in
the right spot and then i see like they
go flying off and maybe like 15 minutes
later i see like a helicopter
with a lift on it and it was like
lifting the person off so i guess they
found her or whatnot but that was that
was crazy there you know so shoot
yeah be careful out there
go hiking crazy times in socal geez
yeah
they got hiking stories for days i could
go on about that you know all in itself
that's crazy
yeah it's dangerous man for sure
yeah you always got to be prepared when
you do any type of stuff like that
100 we've been rock climbing a lot last
year probably once a week ago and um
before then i mean i've been rock
climbing for a long time
but before then
me and my buddy cliff
we would
you know we were used to gym climbs you
know bouldering
and
multiple times we've been we've put
ourselves in this position where we like
almost die where we like climb up to a
thing
and
and it's it's like doable up until a
point where like it's not
immediately it's not doable and right
we're like shoot man uh
look if i fall
i'ma aim for like down there so i only
break my legs
and oh wow it was like oh shoot like i
never want to be in this position i've
been in that position twice and it's it
is not chill
whatsoever so i'm you know ropes climb
with ropes not about climbing without
any ropes
and yeah water said
you did a freeform climb you don't do
ropes or anything like that oh heck no
ropes man ropes all day i got the
freaking
the hooks and the
the carabiners and the
you know all the safety stuff um i don't
mess around anymore that was when i was
like
gym climbing way back in the day when i
thought it was like doable you know oh
we've done this before
right and it's just not
never again man
sketchy
yeah i never i got to get back into
a lighter weight like i want to do rock
climbing but
i think
i put on so much weight during this cove
it i gotta get back down to like a
around 200 ish
for sure i try to do stuff like that for
sure yeah
yeah keep doing them hikes man you'll be
set
yeah now i'm already in a good place i'm
already back in my weightlifting routine
and doing boxing and stuff like that so
good man boxing dude boxing will
i have never been so winded
uh just from boxing two minutes what is
it three minute rounds what's the rounds
i forget yeah well depends what you're
doing but yeah three minutes could be
average yeah like going all out for
three minutes is so difficult
it's all about pacing that's a good
thing about boxing is it teaches you how
to breathe because um
a lot like you can go all out but you
have to be smart about it right so
if you're just going like balls to the
wall and just going crazy then you're
gonna wind out pretty fast and you see
that a lot with like
novice fighters yeah you know it's like
they get excited they go out there and
they they just take all the wins from up
their sales early yeah and then
you know they can't keep their defense
up or anything like that so
breathing is definitely like breathing
techniques and stuff like that is really
really important when it comes to
boxing
absolutely i bet man
uh oh snap it's evolver what's up dude
shout out steven thank you for the super
chat
keep up that workout absolutely man i
did something ah thank you bro
my abs are sore from yesterday i did
this like there's this one video on
youtube it's uh this guy's name's reneer
and it's this 15 minute ab workout with
this dude named rainier and dude he will
get you
it is
it is a difficult one so i'm i'm still
feeling that
all right i got up his name right now
rainier r a n r-a-n-e-i-r
or i-e-r
yeah he does good stuff
um so i have a holoplay
uh capture in here
right now um check it out so basically
once you get your plugin installed right
you should see this little button up
here in the top left it is tiny i i
recognize that
um
but if you just uh go to your settings
plugins you're going to search for holo
and you want to check holoplay you'll
restart your engine
and you'll be set you should see that
little check box so there's a couple
things that you want to do when you get
this in here right so
you'll see let me make this a little
easier for you guys to see and also i am
living on the edge because i cannot save
all right
it won't save the level
so i got to get this
this uh this looking glass file out
before it crashes um
with the holo play capture selected if
you drop down visual you can pump up
these uh displays here
so you can see them a little bit better
i'll do that for you guys bam bam all
right so we have a camera way up here
and it's looking down on the top of this
building
and whatever is in the white is what
will be in focus so that's kind of like
your focus i'll put it like right i'll
put it right there i guess and we can
make this larger we can scale up the
size
to really capture the entire building
and i'm going to do a whole like layout
with this i'm going to
you know i'll i'll
i'll organize these buildings in a way
that looks a little bit better than just
this one but once you have that um i can
go over to this little button here
and
if i should be able i'm gonna toggle the
looking glass real
quick for you guys uh
boom
this is nice the jankiest camera rig set
up right here
but if i hit play bam it'll go here
and you should be able
to see
yes
a 3d building actually
that depth looks really good you can
actually see that in the camera that's
crazy yeah
so yeah if i'm gonna
adjust this here to my eye a little bit
more i'm gonna work on
the field of view so i'm gonna crank the
field of view you can see how it's like
that's a good study in field of view by
the way so
um the
higher your field of view so if i go
this is like a
i don't know who knows what this is
um this could be like a 50 this could be
a 100 millimeter lens it's gonna flatten
the image but if you go wide angle it's
gonna
stretch it way out and make it look like
a skyscraper if you go really intense
with it
um
so we can we can stretch out a little
bit it's a 3d
thing we're doing here um
and if i scroll down
let me show you guys really quick if i
scroll down
to
uh
but you can see here
um
let's see where are we at
uh post processing
bam right here if you click override
depth of field bam then you can start
messing with the depth of field settings
so i'll switch back for you guys
bam bam
and we can start we can check this draw
debug focus plane box
and you can start pushing
where your focus
will be
let's see if we can get it like right up
on
this platform like right there
bam so that's where the focus is and
then you can adjust if i turn that off
you can also adjust
how blurry it is to so
if i take this to 10
oh is that what that look like if i take
it to negative five
should oh it goes to point one is the
lowest so this is probably the lowest we
can go
on the depth of field
yeah it looks pretty dope yeah and then
you can just have like a
little building scene here so i'm gonna
max out this kind of style i'm gonna set
up a scene here so that we can get the
best effect for
for what i'm doing right now so that's
what i'm gonna be working on um also one
one other note um if you guys
are trying to
use nanite with your scene
you're going to want to check this
single view mode box right up in here
that's in the holoplay capture
settings and let me stop the stream
yeah so it's smoother
single view mode um that'll make sure
nana is working properly and yo uh
mepuru a little super chat
says uh what's up
oh you know uh
yeah i actually bought one of his nfts
last year he made a really dope japanese
scene with this um
this like um this glowing cap that was
like the theme throughout his series and
stuff so nice yeah really really dope
work there but yeah glad to see he's in
here i see
what in here as well without wit
the other one we got styles morales too
lee what's going on
yeah i got some friends up in the chat
today yeah i see a lot of dope people in
here on turtle met him at nab
we got kenza
i see dave mellow in here so oh yeah
kenza's in here no way yup what's up
kenza
tweet there's a lot of people from the
game night crew in the house tonight in
fact we got to get you back in there man
we've been playing smash brothers again
and
we're like where's clint you know we
gotta get you back in there we gotta i
gotta get my revenge on donkey kong at
some point yeah dude at some point we'll
see we'll see because
i don't play around i do not mess around
with dk dude uh
you guys i mean i will come back i i
will be there um
you just let me every saturday night
that's every saturday night we're there
that's tonight son
all right
heck yeah
um yeah all right let me see if i can
build out a more pleasing
kind of environment where are you at
wimbush what are you up to
man
mega scans right now because i'm going
to look for some sand that i want to
build out my sand dunes with cool
so i got all my information built out in
row creator i took my grand canyon
terrain that i got from cinema 4d
brought into world creator
kind of made it my own so it's not just
a grand canyon like i use that
information to manipulate it which is
that's the best part about this stuff
especially being an artist in the modern
digital age we can start with something
and completely make it our own and make
something you know completely new from
it so
i did that
i missed out of mega scans bridge right
now which let me actually exit this out
for anybody new in unreal engine 5 it's
actually
um it's integrated with unreal now so
like in the past you would have bridge
installed on your computer and you would
have to like continuously update you
know every time a new iteration came out
but with unreal engine 5 they actually
integrated bridge into the software
which is really dope so this is right
here where you have like this little
green plus arrow if you click on this
you'll just see quick so bridge and you
can also hit the marketplace from here
as well which is really dope so i think
it's cool how they're like really
integrating other acquisitions into
unreal so it's kind of like a one-stop
shop now like we don't have to install
several different programs and all this
stuff is like all just in one program
and you can work a lot faster that way
dude i
keep forgetting that it comes with mega
scans now i'm like opening up bridge i'm
like shoot i gotta like it won't let me
select unreal five it's just four two
seven what the heck i'm like oh that's
because it comes
now i'm waiting for them to install or
integrate quicksilver mixer yup because
i know a lot of people
don't really know the power of mixer yet
but mixer like any substance painter out
there on people out there like mixer
is the quiksil version of that and it's
really really intuitive like i think
their background was actually making
photoshop plugins back in the day
probably like a decade or more and um
so like if you use quiksil mixer it
actually shows really at home if you're
a photoshop user because like everything
is layered based just like it is on
photoshop opposed to how everything is
kind of um node based and you know like
in a substance and so
i've always just kind of taken more
to like the quiksil mixer workflow but
yeah integrate that into unreal that
would be super dope because i that's
like that's another thing that i really
want to get into it's at the top of my
list is some sort of uh substance
painter or mixer and i was like okay
well which one should i go with and
mixer definitely seems a lot more
user-friendly a lot cleaner
um yeah i don't know
like
if they're if i i'm trying to decide
like which one should i get into maybe
mixer because it's free and also it's
easy to use it seems simple it looks
clean
um yeah so that might be my answer right
there
um so i mean if i'll go ahead if you
don't have say if you don't have a
substance description yet then you know
try out mixer but they both have their
plus and minuses right like i know
substance painter has a legacy behind it
and this it's really integrated with
unreal as well so i know um my friend
out there louise like he's been building
out a lot of his stuff in cinema brings
it into substance painter and then
automatically just has his textures go
over to unreal so it's like you can't
really lose with whatever one that
you're using you know but it's like
one's free one is a monthly subscription
so that might come into play as well for
sure
so i'm just downloading
my sand texture right now i went with
the highest quality so it's going to
take like another minute and probably
download this and then
i am going to
use this mega scans texture
to
basically texture out my terrain so this
is another really cool thing that i like
about unreal is i mean it's a game
engine at heart rate so
like if you're building like open world
games and stuff like that you need
really really big landscapes in which
that's where unreal like really thrives
at like making these huge scenes and
stuff like that so
the landscape tool is really really dope
because you can make huge scenes you
know like as far as your eye can see and
yeah it runs at a pretty good frame rate
yeah dude i
recently saw the uh on
on uh
mega scans they released this like
tundra
uh
environment that's massive it looks like
a mile wide i brought it in and it's
ridiculous
i i've never seen them release something
so large like that
there is this one guy this was back in
unreal engine 4. you probably saw the
project it was like a photoreal
australia oh dude memories of australia
absolutely that's one of my that's like
what got me into it
yeah that one was crazy and that one was
pretty massive itself and he was able to
keep up the fidelity like anywhere you
went inside the scene it looked
photoreal that one was pretty crazy
itself i have yet to open that up too
man i think i i really need to
do a better job of digging into the the
projects that that inspire me and learn
from those you know
yeah it helps just at least going in
there and try to backward engineer it
like i think the one that did it for me
was um pixel released a short film back
in the day
and um they really wanted to push the
boundaries of photorealism and unreal
because you know the whole
stigma before it was like unreal only
makes like gaming looking
graphics and so quick so when you kind
of push the bar and show that you can
make like hollywood photo real
type scenarios in there and it looked
really really good so that was kind of
like my case where i'm like okay like
this is the real deal i can actually use
this for work and
that's what really got me into it heck
yeah
yeah it took me a while to figure out
like
how i would specifically use it and
where what gap it feels for me um
and i think i'm starting to figure it
out it basically allows me to
it's just the speed you know it allows
me to bring in whatever build any
terrain see it in real time it's a
really cool way to create and i really
dig it
um right now though i'm actually i'm in
c4d
and instead of
hand placing all these things in
unreal
i'm actually going to clone all these
buildings across a a plane
and
it was a technique actually that i used
um in
an upcoming video on a certain channel
that i won't be able to say much about
at this point but i'm sure you all will
see it
um
and it actually is a really great way to
just randomly place objects and get uh
get a cool little look going so let me
show you guys
real quick so i basically centered
the axis
at the bottom of each one of these
buildings
and if i there's i think two of them are
going to be off
we'll see if i select them all i hold uh
control alt and then i pop them into a
cloner they're all going to sit in that
cloner
yeah this is the one that went off which
one is that
which one is that it has two little
thingies and the little light thingies
on it
this one right here which one e get out
of there bam okay
so
i want to clone these things i want to
clone every single one of these
buildings across this plane
so if i select
my cloner
and i set i know it's really tiny here
but if i set the grid to
object
and i su i set the plane as the object
it will clone all these buildings across
that plane so
they're laying on their side and they're
way too big
so what i'll do is hit transform let's
first rotate them properly so we'll go
negative 90 on that
and then scale i'll scale them all down
to like 0.1 or something there we go
now instead of randomly
distributing these buildings across the
plane i want to distribute them
um let's see instead of surface i will
select
um
vertex
and then okay that will start
yeah
exactly i'm gonna get rid of this corner
one though because it's not really the
vibe right now let's see
this guy
block a let's get rid of that bam
back in also hey i just realized
shout outs uh tom
tom mcnamara what's up dude thank you
for the super chat uh
tom's excited that you're here today
winbush
i appreciate you man
yeah i'm just watching you right now
seeing what you're
so
i see what your tricks are it feels a
little thank you though
um
let's see
so we'll set this to render instance
clones will set to random that way
there's not really a
okay
um
we can
oh here's what we can do we'll take the
segments the width segments just
cut it in half
maybe even four
and then we'll scale these back up
um and in fact since we are on the
looking glass i'm gonna try and match
that like aspect ratio you know what no
i'm just going to scale it up a little
bit more
and we can we can find our frame when we
get into unreal but uh let's see
now how do you plan on bringing that
over are you going to do the data smiths
are you plan on doing a fbx
data smith i think right
um
so what version of cinema 4d are you
using let me ask you that same as yours
they're using 25 or 26 25
okay because the one thing that i did
notice was um
because you know like unreal they they
iterate at a fast pace so once they went
to 5.01
i noticed that the data smith plug-in
works a little bit slower now coming out
of cinema i think they just have to do
like an update or something like that
okay but
um talking to the guys at capacity they
said that um
they're like one of the ogs for doing
like cinema 4d to unreal nice type stuff
and so
when i was at nab and talking with them
they were telling me for their
particular workflow what they do a lot
of now is if something isn't going to be
animating they'll export it out of
cinema 4d
as
in um
as an fbx file and then they mostly only
use the data smith plug-in for stuff
that's animating and that seems to help
out with that workflow there okay that's
just it
it's a tip you know if the data smith is
giving you an issue maybe try that good
to know yeah i'll try it
um i'm actually i'm back in world
creator because i want to make my
dunes a little bit smaller
yeah i'm gonna work on my layout here
too
uh evolver yo back again heck yeah
omniverse
yeah gotta get that omniverse back up
and running um have you messed with
omniverse wimbush at all
it's come to a point to where i can't
ignore it anymore you know because
everybody keeps talking about it so you
know in theory omniverse seemed um
it seemed really dope but i was just
like it might have been too good to be
true so i was just kind of waiting to
seeing but
it keeps um it's making a lot of noise
like a lot of people keep talking about
it and
i'm definitely intrigued at this point
you know it keeps acting like it's
acting right now
i might just have to use it
i might just have to
let me see so i'm re-exporting out
another terrain
i probably went a little bit crazy on my
original one
if you look at my unreal you can see
this doesn't look like dunes at all i
went too crazy on my height dad for sure
can you mess with that in unreal or do
you have to go back into
um you can sculpt like if i go to
landscape here i can actually start
just like it has these sculpting tools
over here so i could smooth it out if i
wanted to like so
let me bring up the strings
so you can see that i could start i mean
it's just like
you know like a sculpting tool right or
i can start flattening it
but
i just like going in
and doing it correct from the get so i'm
probably just going to delete this yeah
and readjust
i'm actually going to delete that
back over to my row creator
and i got so much going on right now
it looks like
it might have froze again
let me close out photoshop real quick i
might just have too much stuff open
not i could just control alt delete and
start it again
oh wow this is kind of funny
i know did it pick up
oh this is nuts
okay i think i'm just gonna overload it
with buildings
oh that's why okay i'm gonna just
restart my real creator i see what i did
sounds good
all right i might bring in some mega
scans and start kit bashing too that has
some cool stuff in there
all right so real creator
so yeah speaking of omniverse have you
jumped in the omniverse at all no
not at all actually yeah
so the interesting thing at least the
way they were pitching it to me was um
no matter what dcc or even you know like
imagine that you're using everybody who
work on the same project at once so like
if you're working in cinema and i'm
working in maya and we have another
person working in unreal all remote like
everybody could work on the same file no
matter
which software they're using which
that's the part where i'm like that's
too good to be true but i've been seeing
people use it and it seems legit you
know
yeah absolutely i think it's something
that would be perfect for these streams
too because then we could just
collaborate on the same thing
yeah i mean
we definitely should figure it out and
try it at some point
absolutely i know uh evolver is all
about it uh he's worked he works with it
pretty closely so
um oh yeah yeah definitely definitely
all right let's see what do you think do
you think
unreal can handle this fbx
this is a this is an fbx right here
yeah i think so it should be good okay
all right let's give it a shot
i could take it a second or two to
import but yeah i think it should be
good
beef
all right what are you thinking about
texture wise for it you're just gonna
you're gonna like a more stylized look
with it yeah yeah i'm not gonna try and
link all these textures um
no way
not now they're not set up so
uh all right let's get
where are you unreal did i no there it
is
i have two copies of unreal open and
cinema 4d
that's what's up all right
okay um
let's give it a shot
all right so
now i gotta open back up photoshop
actually no i don't need photoshop i
could just bring this into unreal
all right so i'm gonna go back to my
landscape tool
i'm gonna re-import
my height map
okay so that looks a little bit better
all right fit the data
and i'm gonna import
let's see what kind of results we get
now
actually i'm going to close out my
photoshop
yeah see this is where my ultra wide
kicks in because i'm so used to having
like so many programs opened up once
yeah
i actually want to get
like i have a 4k monitor by seuss that's
been kind of just nice chilling i do
want to try to maybe hook it up as like
a vertical monitor like a second monitor
type thing
is it one of those like really nice
like color profile set ones
oh my god dude yeah you got to get that
thing up and running
looks like my height is still
not where i want it to be let me see
the people just make the adjustment
instead of unreal i hit it with that big
smooth
brush or something
well if i come in
i know
it's kind of frowned upon but if i
change the scale to maybe 25
get and then hit import oh got you you
don't
my only issue is my height data is
coming in too hot and it's like i kind
of want it to be a little bit more
smooth you know so
all right now let's see hold
yeah so something like that is a little
bit more
suffice those look like dunes
it'll probably go a little bit higher on
it so i'm gonna hit ctrl z
let's go back
make it maybe like 50 percent
import
and i can also keep bash out the scene
too like this is just bringing in the
terrain but then you want to kind of
bring in geometry on top of that just to
really
you know like polish it out of course
so let me see where i'm at right now
something like that doesn't look bad
let me see what's going on with my
texture here
i could probably even bring up my
texture scale
i'm come over here
instead of my mega skins texture
let's see tiling i always get this wrong
so maybe point one let me see how that
looks ah there we go so now we have some
nice looking sand in here i could
probably even go a little bit bigger
point zero five
it looks nice so
save
and especially up close like that looks
really really dope right there
that's great uh
let me find a good spot maybe
somewhere around here yeah the mountains
like kind of vignette and scoop up on
the sides it's nice
yeah and i can even put some
some mega scan stuff in there as well so
[Music]
let me see i'm going to delete this
atmosphere
i'm going to keep that light source in
there actually let me see what kind of
hdrs i have
so i'm going to come over to my adobe
bridge
come on to my content folder right click
i'm just going to make a new folder call
it hdr
and i mean this will work for any
application let me actually open up
firefox because this is something that's
really dope
that i feel like not enough people know
about this resource
so if i go to hdir
haven dot com you probably know this oh
yeah best man
yeah so if he they even have like
textures and stuff like that too so
if you come over oh they must have
changed it now it's called polyhaven.com
but if you go to
hdrhdrihaven.com it will bring you to
the site but if you click right here
which is browse hdrs
i mean it has a whole plethora and
different hdrs in here i mean they have
hundreds and hundreds of them and
they're all absolutely free but you
could donate you know to the people if
you really
want to just you know go and support but
let's say you want to use like this hdr
right here you just click on it
you can pick a different format you
could do hdr or exr
or you could do up to 24k as well which
that's kind of that's overkill but i
mean
this is
these are legit hdrs like i use this
site all the time it's the best hdrs for
lighting and stuff so yeah there's like
no other
there's no other
place to go to be let's just be honest
yep
so i'm actually going to i have a bunch
downloaded already which i have inside
my
adobe bridge which i like looking at
just uh
i don't know i like the way bridge is
laid out a lot better than file explorer
oh interesting
i never use it yeah
yeah it's nice especially um
like when i used to do freelance work
right
and work at studios a lot of times it
was mac based and so i got used to using
like their file explorer that are on
apple computers and stuff yeah and this
really reminds me of like that you know
like the way that like when you look at
the images they're all there and the
videos and stuff like that and how it
was able to bring in
different formats for viewing so i don't
know just it feels a lot more nicer to
me than like the file explorer so nice i
will often use that
hey guess who's in the chat
who's that james
pixels yep what's up james uh
plugged my laptop back in my
thing actually wasn't plugged in so i
think the battery died
but yeah now what up james thank you for
stopping by
dude my my import was gonna take 25
minutes
why not fbx yes
i'm just gonna try the better smith
i'm just gonna hand place it let's just
i'm gonna hand place it so i can get
this piece done so i can i have a bunch
of ideas that i really want to do for
this looking glass so i want to see if i
can just get them
all right
so
all right so i got this hdr
i drag and dropped it into my unreal
inside my content browser and so this is
a tip to like just two ways of doing
hdrs inside of unreal well there might
be more but these are the two that i
know about so
like if you come over here to where it
says lights
and then you click on hdr backdrop you
can click on that and it will actually
make like a physical dome inside your
scene here
so
just wait for that to drop in there but
that's if you actually want to like see
your hdr inside your scene right
in which
not sure why
it froze on me
but trust me it does all right
so
that's good to know because i've been
trying to learn i've been trying to get
the hdr in there uh myself so that's
good to know for
sure well check this out because we have
a dome in here right and so this dome
is basically it's a half film right so
it's a 180 dome and you could just drag
and drop your hdrs in there so if you
have like a smaller scene per se yeah
and you could use this and you can
actually see like your hdr and it will
actually light everything as well like i
could drag this up
it kind of make it look a bit nicer
but
basically you're living inside the hdr
and at the dome but for like our scene
right here like if i go outside my dome
you can see it only encompasses
it so much and so you know if you have
like a smaller scene and you want to see
your hdr that's one way to go about it
but if you have a larger scene i'm
actually going to get rid of that like
we have here i'm actually going to come
over to my skylight right here it's in
my world outliner and if i come over
here let me drag this over hopefully the
people can see it might be a little bit
small but if i come over here under
light you can see that it says source
type and if i click on right here where
it says sls
you can see that we have one it would
say sls specified cube map so if i click
on this
we can actually now drop in the hdr into
like this little box here that has like
a pink underline so if i click and drag
this into here
now you can see our scene is being lit
by hdr so let me actually go back
because you might not have seen that
and actually i could turn off my
my um sunlight right there
let me do that again so i'm going to go
to skylight
drag my hdr into the cube map
and now my scene is centered by the hdr
and then you can actually
change the light color so i don't like
using just white you know maybe add
a little bit of tint to it just to kind
of make it look a little bit more
realistic yeah so like i'm adding a
little bit of oranges brown to it like
so
and then you can come down here you can
cast shadows if you want or not
but i'm gonna go down here to intensity
scale
maybe start at like 0.4
i'm going to bring my sunlight back in
and it's kind of like going back and
forth between the two right just to kind
of get your your lighting that suffice
for your scene
so
i like going back and forth between
those two
is there a way to link it with your son
can you have the hdri in the sun
together
um
i want to say you can i'm trying to
think
um just curious to think of how you were
able to yeah i know you could do it but
i'm trying to think of
because there's this guy who makes his
plugin called um
brushify his name is joe garcia oh yeah
and i took his class and he actually
showed you how to do it in his class but
i for the life of me i just can't i got
you remember how to do it right now
but
yeah because that's his way of how he
goes about it like he'll take his hdr
attach it to the sunlight and have them
like all rotating at once
yeah to kind of really make it more
realistic looking but
that's how that's how i usually do it in
c4d
with octane yeah
yep
which makes a ton of sense
all right i got my laptop back up and
running
what up jill or will jane
in the house i just got my chat back up
but let me see what we got inside of
mega scans because i want to add
some mega scans to the scene to kind of
flush it out a little bit
because that backdrop
just looks kind of boring there so i
definitely want to put something
different in here
so if i come over to
i'm in my quick show bridge
i want to come over to
collections
this is another cool thing like or not
epic but quicksole actually
will give you specific like materials
and geometry and stuff like that that
are inside like a specific um
collection i guess you would say so like
the way the quixote team works like they
travel the entire world taking photo
scans of textures of objects and a lot
of times like all the stuff that they
shoot in one geological location they'll
pack that together so everything will be
kind of um
i guess cohesive yeah totally so like if
i
if you look down here inside your
collection
you can see like okay the tundra pack
right here so
everything inside the tundra pack this
was all shot in one location and then
they they kind of make it a collection
so
if you wanted to make a scene that
looked really cohesive then you have
everything in that pack that you need
you know so you don't have to like kind
of figure it out on your own which is
really dope yeah it makes things easy do
you see that giant
landscape in the tundra pack
if you scroll up maybe you should see
like a massive
landscape it's probably in there
somewhere it has like water in it you
can see like water
on it oh yeah i know this one has water
yes that one those yeah ridiculous
and that water because i actually did
use this and um that water in there it's
actually reflective like even though
it's like a photo scan i'm not sure how
they did it but it's actually reflective
water in there so if you put in your
scene it's actually going to reflect you
know everything that you have in your
environment so cool
yeah like these guys don't
mess around when it comes to like making
the best of the best you know when it
comes to photogrammetry assets yeah
they are the kings
yeah i'm trying to find a good
let's see
maybe
this limestone quarry
which is actually the one that they used
for the um
the unreal five demo
like a year ago when they made like that
fake tomb raider looking thing yeah
yeah these are all the assets from that
so maybe i can make something
dope with these assets
actually let me see what else we have
do the canyons of utah that might
actually
let's see what we got in here
hey wimbush
wait up
what was the
what was like the first thing that got
you into 3d or visual effects or any or
even creativity what was the first thing
um
i don't know i think i've just always
been like a gamer from heart like i
started with like a tandy 1000 for those
that remember the old school computers
with the floppy disk that had like a
black screen with
you know like the green text and you had
to um like i used to play like dungeons
and dragons and stuff where you actually
had to like print out on the dot matrix
printer
and
it's like the text would come up and you
would have to like think like you had
have to use your imagination on what's
happening like you look back and forth
between the screen and the documents
that you printed out and kind of you're
playing d and d but it's all imagination
so i think that's where like my creative
i guess um
my set kind of came from like just
always imagining stuff in my head yeah
and then like fast forward when we're
actually able to make like cg graphics
and bring that stuff into reality i
think that's why
i was kind of really drawn to it so it's
kind of like putting the best of both
worlds together right like i was always
a massive gamer i was always a massive
thinker i was a tanker i used to take
technology break it apart
try to reassemble it that type of stuff
and so
yeah i think it's just a whole plethora
of
you know just the stars aligning in just
me always being able to be exposed to
you know creative stuff as a young child
what was the first thing like the first
program you hopped into
um
print shop print show you
it was
like a clip art program yeah way before
this is probably in like the late 80s so
i was probably like
9 or 10 at the time but yeah it was like
you would make like it would the program
would come with like a ton of clip art
it was only black and white you could
drag and drop all your stuff into your
scene um it had like type tools and
stuff like that so i used to just go in
there and kind of you know it's like
like playing with legos right i would
just go in there
kind of play around making goofy little
scenes and stuff like that and you know
just being creative so that was probably
like the very first creative tool that i
ever used you know
that's awesome
and then what was your first job like
what was the first thing that
you started getting paid for it
um my very first
hollywood job would have been
fantastic for rise of the silver surfer
i got to work on the main titles for
that movie that was your first job as
like first paid job as a 3d artist or as
2d even 2d
um yeah i went all in that was after i
graduated from i went to the art
institute of pittsburgh okay and
got a
an internship over at
um under adam stanler over there at
happy madison he had like a motion
graphics shop of his happy madison
production company called framework and
so i was working there doing motion
graphics and um
yeah we had the opportunity to do the
main titles for the fantastic four
movies so just being a huge comic book
nerd when the opportunity was there like
i begged to get on there i'm just like i
really want to work on it yeah this
marvel film and i didn't even know
cinema 4d back then right like when i
was in art school they taught us
um 3d max xsi softimage and maya
so i never heard a c4d until i started
working in hollywood and at that time
they were just like yeah we're
we're using cinema 4d for this main
title do you know it and i wanted to
work on it so bad that i kind of just
lied it was like yeah i know
that's what's up who doesn't you know so
i stayed at the studio every night till
like two in the morning just banging it
out you know back this was back when uh
there was no like youtube or anything
right like it was all just big sick
manuals
so i would read the manual at the studio
in the off hours and
just really try to hone in my skill set
and
got good enough to where i was able to
you know work on the main titles there
and come up with some dope stuff so
that's awesome yeah that
what gets you excited now like
what what's out of all the things
that there are to create there's a
million things to create there's a
million programs to use what gets you
the most amped
um
new technology as a whole
sorry my dog's going crazy somebody just
rang a doorbell
but um
yeah just new technology as a whole
right like um
whenever i started in motion graphics we
used to do stuff like um everything
wasn't done in the computer right like
we used to take physical objects and try
to manipulate real world stuff in camera
and then incorporate that into motion
graphics which i feel like a lot of
people don't do these days and so like
at the biggest example i have is like
we were trying to do like fluid
simulations for a tv show this was
probably about like 2008
and i think back then the only fluid sim
software we had was real flow which is
really slow at that time everything the
cpu base and
yeah it's pretty new but um
so we were having trouble getting the
fluid sims to do what we wanted and so
basically what we had did was
we got like a giant fish tank um i
forget how many gallons it was but we
got a giant fish tank we got a phantom
camera so that we could shoot at like
120 frames per second we got like all
these different ink pouches and
everything
that we um that we would just throw
inside the fish tank and we would shoot
at like a hyper speed on the phantom
camera there and we would just film like
the different ways that the ink would
react inside the water and then we
brought that into after effects and we
would manipulate it and that's basically
how we got you know like our fluid sims
and everything back didn't it so that's
legit i feel like
yeah i feel like a lot of that stuff is
kind of missing
with motion graphics artists these days
just like the willingness to really
go in the experiment and play around and
not be
kind of tied to your computer all the
time like just go out there and
see what you can manipulate and kind of
make your own yeah it's the real world
element that
that makes i think that ties
the cg world to the real world obviously
and um
yeah yeah i i started out in visual
effects um
and doing just pure 3d stuff
is very new for me um
and
it's definitely it has it's nice to be
able to do just
pure 3d because you have to work
compositing is so difficult
um
to make it blend
it's just so darn difficult sometimes
and
it's nice to just work in 3d it feels
great
now what about
like trying to
bring like raw elements into your 3d and
stuff like that
real elements into 3d oh man um well if
you're talking stock footage if you're
talking like
you know i'll use like action vfx stuff
i'll use their like smoke or whatnot um
and that
is is definitely helpful do you mean
like something like that
well you're starting to you're getting
the photogrammetry stuff right because
you're starting to show me how to do a
lot of photogrammetry stuff
yeah yeah that's a i guess that's a good
it's an interesting way to to put it too
is yeah photogrammetry can be considered
real elements brought into 3d um
i didn't think i actually didn't think
of that
but it makes total sense yeah um
that stuff is really fun i just love
things when they look photo real that to
me is just when you're able to touch it
when it's tangible
um when it feels like it could be a real
thing when you create a world that was
in your head but now it's out on the
screen and it looks real that's so much
fun to me
right
yeah for me
like um
i don't know i feel like
in motion graphics especially like we've
been chasing that fertile dragon for so
long that now that we're able to obtain
it it doesn't um
for me personally like
doesn't really do much for me anymore
because it's so easy to obtain though so
like i like really stylized stuff like
especially like i said you know really
big in the gaming and stuff like that so
you know like breath of the wild that
type of style looked really dope to me
and some of the stuff that anime studios
are incorporating
with like 3d into like traditional anime
2d and stuff like that it's really dope
so
i really do enjoy like more stylized
stuff these days i think taste always
kind of changes yeah i agree because i
feel like there's a lot of photo real
art out there and
a lot of it doesn't hit the mark i feel
like it has to be
it has to be like on point
if it's gonna work for me
but right yeah i i feel very similar
where it's like
i need some sort of stylized thing
because there's just so much photoreal
stuff out there so what it's like what
else are you doing
new
and what else are you bringing to the
table so
agreed
yeah plus i mean i'm just i like anime a
lot too so i think yeah i'm kind of
persuaded by that that style in general
you know anytime i see anybody post
something like dope anime stuff on like
instagram or twitter that they did
themselves i'm always all about that
do you know um
recognition
yeah yeah i know him personally same
yeah dude that guy is
so good ken said yeah he's legit yep
yeah
his stuff is insane
yeah kenton is legit
i love his um
i love his pixel art style like he does
pixar stuff too that's really really
dope
yep that's the like
that's kind of my favorite stuff of his
to be honest
yeah because um
i forget what the artist name is there's
another pixel artist he did like the um
i can't think of what the game is he
does a lot of stuff for adult swim so
anytime you see like the pixar stuff on
adult swim that's usually his stuff
that's awesome
yeah kenton reminds me a lot of him
even though i can't remember his name
but yeah those artists are
super dope
it's a style i wanna i really wanna do
but i feel like i would have to i'd have
to go in deep to the books
and learn a lot of new stuff which isn't
a bad thing at all
yeah i've asked him on how he does it
he's explained it to me but it's one of
those things i think it's going to take
some um
some practice you know yeah for sure
so i got this desert dragon in here
let me see
i dropped him into the scene
[Music]
so i just think i just want to
i don't know if i'm going to have this
animate i just want to make something
that looks
pretty dope here
maybe make like a dragon cave and uh the
sand dunes here
nice
actually
my lighting keeps going
up and down for my exposure so i'm going
to add like a post-press volume in here
to try to control that a little bit
let me see i'm gonna come over here to
and that your audience probably already
knows but i can ask you the same like
what really got you into
like this field as a
whole um
[Music]
it was i was always in the drawing but
it was
when my friend bobby showed me
how a video camera worked
i i didn't know how it like cut from one
image to another
and that blew my mind so he like filmed
over here he filmed over there
and then
um
you know showed me playback and it cut
perfectly i was like wow
that blew my mind freaking crazy
um
and
from there i was like okay well let's
film a fight scene
and then i had a bunch of airsoft guns
so he showed me windows movie maker
and i realized like oh shoot okay so i
can film a little airsoft video
uh and then add the muzzle flashes per
frame in
it was macromedia fireworks at the time
i think was the name of the oh yeah i
remember that yep yeah um
and then i discovered
andrew kramer and then it was
uphill from there or downhill whichever
whichever way
um
so that was yeah that was it i just love
being able to create stuff so i think it
started early on when i wanted to draw
also got to give a shout out to my boy
devon williams he's one of my groomsmen
he's gonna be here next week um shout
outs man he said paul robertson is the
pixel artist you were talking about
winbush
oh yeah that's it yup
definitely follow him on instagram or at
least check his stuff out because his
stuff is super legit
that's awesome thanks devon appreciate
that and also styles what's up dude you
found a perfect beat for the track heck
yeah
yeah this guy uh reached out to me
styles morales and he was like man i'm
gonna i'm gonna write you
like a little little hip hop song i'm
gonna
write some lines write some bars for it
and
i'm like all right man i've never even
imagined what that would sound like
so maybe maybe you'll see it on the
stream who knows we will see but i
appreciate both you guys thanks for the
for the super chats
devon i'm glad you're here too man
that's awesome
spencer
i know a couple spencers do you is this
is this one of the spencers i know
personally
all right i'm trying to think
i could spend hours tweaking this it's
so hard to work and talk at the same
time it really is
um yeah now i feel you man
i'm gonna hop into a new level
i am just trying to make something so
that i can throw it into my looking
glass to
check it out so i'm feeling like this
desert kv type thing right now sweet and
have like the
this desert dragon is going to be my
hero for the scene right here
so the dragon is actually animated but i
don't think i want to
do an animation for this i want to just
make like a nice composite for sure
composition yeah
i'm actually going to
tighten up my scene a little bit add
some folders in here
oh man it's so weird going from
navigating in unreal to navigating in
c4d it's all feels all weird
uh i would love it if um
maxon
would give the option of um dude
navigating the way to unroll this
because like once i got i mean
especially playing video games right
like holding the mouse and hitting the
wasd
to control your your um
your navigation instead of unreal i mean
once you get used to it it's hard to go
back you know to the way like
traditional dcc's operate so it's so
just like it i feel like it flows out of
me as soon as i hop down like oh this is
how you do it oh perfect
there's no other way to do it right
yeah i mean it's literally like playing
the video game like we were trying to
hold lives for this yep
and it's so quick too
like i'm sure the audience is probably
played around with it but like if i just
right click on my mouse and
start using wasd like on my keyboard you
can see i'm just like
flying around my scene here like there's
nothing like this is
this is crazy and we could just go over
like massive terrains for some moments
yeah it's this is
this was probably one of the most things
when i discovered unreal engine just
like being able to just go through my
environment like this and i'm just like
man this is crazy like we're able to
move this fast within our viewport
because you know before
um what other dccs like
sometimes
your geometry or the way you have your
scene built out it would just start
getting really heavy
and it would be hard you know to move
around and you're seeing this stuff but
it's like with this i could throw the
kitchen sink at it and still be good
absolutely
it's it's creepy how
well unreal handles all this stuff
yeah to the point to where i felt like i
sounded like an infomercial for
epic you know because it's like i'm
always telling people like yo you gotta
check this out like this thing is
it's fast it's legit you know it's very
exciting yep
um all right
can you paint
with the paint tool you can paint like
objects right
um
oh yeah you could paint objects in there
with the scatter tool
okay i think i'm gonna try that
see i can show you if you want real
quick
does it work the same as foliage
yep 100 okay
all right
i'm gonna give that a shot i'm gonna i'm
gonna go for my second idea here
hopefully i can get this up and running
faster
all right so let's see you're saying
if we go
what is it shift f3
uh
foliage or shift three foliage ship
three drop the foliage oh that works
okay
sweet there you go
all right that's great uh let's chill
out on that brush size works the same as
photoshop brackets
got you
um
let's
make that density a little less dense
bam
that was another one of my favorite
tools when i discovered unreal like they
added it to cinema 4d now like i was
telling the guys over there i'm like
guys you got to check this out like
i always caught it like the bob ross
tool right just like painting and
spoilage and
yeah it was just crazy how fast it was
and finally you know cinema added you
know the scatter tool to it which worked
similar but
that was one of the things that i loved
about unreal was bringing in any object
being able to just paint it onto your
your geometry right like no matter what
your geometry was it just automatically
knew what the surface was and yeah it
was just really intuitive
yeah super smart
um
emily hey thank you for the super chat
uh you'd like to thank
for the content tutorials help a lot
with university work and your videos
keep me motivated that's what's up
thank you emily i appreciate you
glad i'm able to help out a little bit
that's nice
you know we're doing what we can
all right while i'm waiting for this
object to import the static mesh so i
was just going to look at the chat
um
someone said how does window bush does
it
not get the red x on the point lights
being the same three plus times on the
same radius
um
yeah well it's one bush for one get it
right papaxo
yeah not window but no it's all good i
know sometimes the spell check but um
it looks like my screen kind of froze up
here but
whenever i click on my light i make it a
movable light and so whenever you bring
it in um
it will make it like it's that or not
static um what's that middle tier i
forget which one it is but
stationary
stationary that's right but once it
opens back up then you can make it
movable
and that should help you right there
so yeah let me click on my light
yeah so when you bring it in that will
come in a stationary or a static but you
make it movable just like so and the
lights should be um they should be fine
i'm gonna make this
a massive
engine here
it should probably start bringing stuff
into the looking glass right definitely
seeing how is how it's looking
i wanted to bring this canyon in here
try to help with some of the shadowing
on my dragon there let me see got my my
dragon i could probably add a little bit
more light in here well i guess it
depends on
actually let me add
some atmospheric fog and see what how
that system moved
sometimes exponential height fog yeah
that helps set the mood always
looks great
see you come down here make it
volumetric fog
there we go
let me change my albedo a little bit
make the fog
maybe a little bit into the orangish
reds
somewhere like that
okay i'm gonna click save and then i'm
gonna bring in
i'm just gonna bring it into my looking
glass just to kind of see what it looks
like because it's gonna look definitely
different than what's in unreal actually
i should bring out my dragon
just to add a little bit of depth to it
maybe rotate him over like so
actually after i'm done with this scene
like i was working on a project with um
with message man i'm working on like a
comic book with him right now
nice so i turned him into a cg superhero
and um
i did like this 3d animation instead of
unreal with him and stuff so i'm going
to see how that looks inside the looking
glass but i don't want to look pretty
dope
it's kind of like method man with a
combination of like moon knight and luke
cage and he's looking over the new york
city skyline and stuff that's awesome
that might look actually dope inside the
looking glass
so i'm gonna save my scene out real
quick
and then
actually i need to activate the plugin
right so i need to come over
come down to
area edit plugins
let's type in
hollow yeah just the one hello play
and hit restart i'm gonna allow this to
restart my scene
excuse me
what do you got going on over there i'm
trying to get
um
i'm trying to get it so
the shadows from the point light
you can kind of like as you look around
the scene
you're you're able to like
reveal
other things behind like i'm trying to
occlude other pieces here
with this right um
let's see
do i take it full screen well i'm
loading my under backup
um
yeah let me see
i think i need a denser mesh of
these guys let's see
or come to a different
i'm just working on my camera adjustment
for some reason when i
restarted unreal my camera popped out
for a minute there
that's all good
yep did my camera come back in
not yet
i wonder if it's my
actually i probably gotta come over
you got it yeah
perfect
oh
yeah thank you
all right cool so i'm going to
i've restarted my unreal engine
and now i can bring the hollow play into
my scene
so i'm going to come down here to
all right so i have this box over here
right next to select mode we have the
screen this green plus symbol i'm going
to click on this
come down here to all classes and then
i'm going to come all the way down i'm
just going to scroll down to the h's
versus hollow play capture like so so
i'm going to click on this
bring it into my scene just how we did
it before when we initially started the
the stream here and so now we have like
this blue box in here i'm just going to
actually rotate this blue box with the
camera attached to it
so i have my dragon encompassing
my box here
let me see
because i don't want to get clipping by
the sand so i just want to make sure
maybe add this little rotation on here
like so
i'm actually going to play it through my
looking glass and my frame rate might
drop a little bit here
okay so i'm just going to adjust
it inside my looking glass real quick
before i show a camera
but the depth that i'm getting on this
dragon is really dope
oh that looks good right there
and
remember my camera around i'm getting
into a good position
the lighting is a little bit different
as well so i might want to drop another
light in here to light the front of his
face a little bit
so yeah i wish i had a second camera
it's all good
in here
next time yeah i'm about done with
with this i can probably show this off
soon
i'm gonna drag it light over here on his
face
like so
because we have some nice specular on
the dragon as well
all right let me click play again
bring it into my looking glass
oh that looks dope so i'm gonna hold
this up the camera
let me see
if you guys can see it i'm trying to
look
for my camera as well
oh
yeah
that's so so we don't see the background
as much but the background is casting
shadows on him and everything and
the light which kind of makes him look a
little bit more realistic in there but
yeah that that's looking pretty dope the
depth is pretty good on there too
yeah that's really nice the lighting
works too i think um
i think
so lumen
doesn't work
with the glass right now
um oh yeah how do i how do i adjust that
so
uh
i forgot all about that yeah i think you
just need to turn lumen off
in your
post process volume
potentially that's probably why you're
not seeing what you're seeing so i would
start like one light at a time and light
it with uh
i think if you switch to
let's see
actually i'm in my post processing i can
actually switch my lighting
to ray tracing yeah maybe yeah
so i'm gonna change my reflections is it
just lighting or reflections actually i
think everything
all right so i'm gonna do reflections to
screen space
all right here we go global elimination
i am going to do
green space
yes
believe so
[Music]
that looks crazy
yeah
i i don't think that was the right one
let me turn that back off okay yeah so
global elimination i probably want to
switch this to none
because it it put like this crazy
rainbow effect on there i probably
should have killed that too so
yeah if you look right there
you can see
that's where i put screen space on whoa
dude that's insane so
it looks like the old school holograms
when you get like the the tops cards you
know like the baseball players
but
yeah so that's not going to work so
we're going to um
actually i could probably go into the
project settings and switch out turn off
lumen that way so
let me put my [ __ ] glass down here
like so
oh
looks like you got
a superchat in there as well
oh neotex
what's up you working previous post vids
you're transitioning to unreal for a lot
of work
not a fan of maya right now so slow the
ue pipe is more up front work but so
earth has a main compositor yeah it's
really fun i feel like it fills a lot of
feels um fills a void that we all need
as artists here you know it's it's
really fun to
get your stuff set up and see it in real
time and work on it so
it's been a blast it's really deep i
feel like the program itself is really
steep it's very manual but once you get
the hang of it it's totally worth it so
um
yeah
agreed thanks for the super chat i
appreciate you very much
i mean i can't do a plug right here if
you want you know i did do some stuff at
mograph.com right
yeah so i did a beginner's course for
unreal engine five i can actually
i can actually pull it up on my web
browser right here so throw a link
in the chat too
what up with the the chat at because i'm
on my computer
oh um maybe soto can
can uh can find it for us
yeah so if you go to mograph.com and
then you come over to classes
this will show you
all the
classes.mograph.com like they actually i
did a unreal engine 4 course through
them last year
it's loading up pretty slow there we go
so it's called creating the unreal
with jonathan winbush and so this is
more geared towards motion graphics
artists like i do have a section on
there
on cinema 4d to unreal engine but you
don't have to use cinema 4d right like
i've had people that have used blender
that jumped into this course as well
they said it helped out because
a majority of it is done inside of
unreal engine so i basically take you
from you know somebody that's never
touched unreal to people that are able
to like start rendering stuff out and
creating their own projects in there
it's about 10 hours worth of content but
again this is unreal engine 4 but a lot
of the concepts do translate over into
five
and so yeah anybody that wants to get
started out
it's right there you know and then i
also have a ton of stuff on my youtube
channel as well like i have
over
300 tutorials on youtube and stuff
a lot of them are you know unreal engine
tutorials so
i learned a lot from you man um
yeah if you guys are trying to learn c4d
or unreal engine winbush is the way
the first tutorial i ever found from you
was the
realflow tutorial um your water down the
stream
like that tutorial
oh my god dude that thing
looks so real
that was ridge shift too yeah
god dang
i think what was
your camera
oh it did
i wonder what is going on here
you know what if you want to go full
screen i have another capture card that
i could try out real quick
sounds good
all right cool i'm gonna turn this
camera off because i feel my cam like
it is it feels a little bit hot so i
wonder if it's overheating so let me
switch over to this other camera
that sounds good
all right let's see what this looks like
on the glass
so cool
oh man i love the fact that you can
actually see around it
as insane
i feel like you could definitely use
like a green kind of grass
material here on this thing
so let's see if we can't just hop in
to bridge
and find something
no we're not 3d plants surfaces
yet
okay so i just plugged in another
hdmi source
let me see
you hear that they added a
displacement textures to qixel
no i didn't
they added the whole library
oh yeah yeah rdt that's right they
bottom out
that's nuts
so
my camera is it up now
um i'm not sure soto
yeah awesome okay yeah i use this other
capture card that i have so we should be
good
back in business
oh good
all right so i think i turned off
i think i turned off lumen now in my
scene so let me actually try it again on
my looking glass
see how that looks let me know and i'll
switch it over to you
yeah i think i'm good now let me see
yep
that's so freaking cool
here we go
yeah we'll have to make this into a
quill
so we can share this out
yeah do you want to export it
um yeah i could do that now and then i
could start up another scene here yeah
sounds good
yeah no i'll set this one off and then
i want to definitely bring method man
into here and see how that looks
cool i'll wrap this one up as you do
that i'll do one more when we switch
over because it's about 12 45 now um
we can both do a quick one each
um
after we wrap these up
i mean do you want me to do a quill
afterwards or do you want me to walk
through the process of nothing on the
live
go for it
all right so i'm going to
add level sequence here to my scene
um i'm just going to leave it here new
level sequence nothing fancy
and that's going to bring up our
sequencer if you're not familiar with
unreal our sequencer is basically our
timeline right and so this is where
everything that we want to render out
we're going to drag and drop into here
so
well camera wise right so i'm going to
drag and drop my holo play capture into
here and actually i should probably turn
it off on my looking glass
like so
all right cool and i'm not going to
animate the camera i think i'm just
going to do a still frame so i'm
actually just going to maybe go up
like one frame maybe
and hit my end point there
like so
so basically i'm just going to be
rendering out one frame
and then i have to
i'm trying to oh so we want to lock into
main viewport you definitely want to
make sure that you have this checked on
and then over here again these three
dots that are next to the looking glass
logo you want to come down here where it
says play in quilt mode so you want to
have that selected as well so again
lock in main viewport and play in quilt
mode and this is going to make sure that
we're allowed to export out
into quilt mode for our looking glass
and so right here where you see this
little clipboard i'm back inside my
sequencer we have three dots right here
i'm going to left click on it and you
can see that we have two different
render types we have the render movie
queue which is the current way of
rendering it was added in 4.26
and that's how people would normally
render now right but we also have the
legacy way which is the order way that
we used to use back in 4.25 and before
and that's the one that we want to use
right there because that's the one that
we have set up with holo play and it's
going to give us the correct settings
that we need so make sure you have this
one this is legacy
selected and then i'm going to click
back on the the clipboard here
and this is going to bring up my movie
rep or my move my favorite top my render
movie settings and right here where it
says image output format i'm just going
to click on this make a png file
and then under resolution i want to make
sure that i do
3840x3840 it will say portrait hires
click on this one right here
then i'm just going to make a new folder
on my desktop here
so let me just name this one dragon
like so
i will select that select folder
and then
uh do you remember
that well i just use it this way right i
don't remember that um oh i got you
special okay it's uh q
s yeah underscore first separate
q s
eight x six
eight x six
okay so under file format
at the very end i just did underscore
qs8 x6
and that what does that do again so that
just makes sure that it frames it up for
your your looking glass right no so that
is when you bring it into the hollow
place studio looking glasses software it
um
it auto by default will set the right
settings in in uh
yeah
okay
cool so now i'm gonna hit capture movie
it's gonna say save selected
this should just take a moment to save
out here
and while it's doing that i can actually
open up hollow play studio like so
yeah there we go looks like unreal
is rendering
yeah you can see all the dragons
right there
all right cool so it looks like unreal
is done rendering
i'm going to come over
let me actually
take this one out
come over to my windows explorer
look for my desktop here
i'm going to go to dragon
you can see on my png file right here
i'm just going to click and drag it
into my holoplay studio which is looking
glasses um their software that you can
export stuff out to the looking glass
you can make playlists and stuff like
that so i'm going to select quilt photo
and video i'm going to click on this
click ok
and now if i play
it should show up in my i have to sync
my playlist first
click accept
thinking from computer to looking glass
did not shut down or shut off as it may
corrupt do you have your hdmi
plugged in yep okay yep everything is
plugged in so i'm just waiting for this
to sync up
um it might be
is your light blue or white on the side
of your glass
it's blue and i'm actually seeing like
it's showing up in my display here and
everything perfect okay there we go sync
the playlist
and there we go so now what's inside the
playlist
that's what's inside my looking glass
there so now
we can actually i can send this over to
clint or we can upload it to the looking
glass to the little drop section that
they have and you guys if you have a
looking glass you could view what we
just created here as well which is
really dope so we can share that off to
the community heck yeah so at the end of
the stream once things wrap up probably
probably an hour so after the stream
that'll be in the description for you
guys um i'm gonna do this little lantern
scene for you and then uh
maybe one more i'll probably upload some
of the ones that i've done in the past
let me actually show you
really quick what i've what i've done
here
um
yeah i'm just reopening up unreal i'm
going to open up that wu-tang project i
was talking about
so this was a test that i did earlier in
the week this is just some mega scans
assets and like you can actually it's a
little bit difficult to tell but there
is a light right here that you can see
you can see like the angle of this light
and based on when you move this thing
it'll actually change the lighting you
can change the reflection and the
specular as you change angles
you can look into this box
you can include the box so it's super
cool
what else do we have
what is this
oh we don't talk we don't we don't talk
about that all right um we got
yosemite boys uh this is at my bachelor
party
turned this i just did a little 2d to 3d
conversion
uh with looking glasses software you got
that link in the description as well
windbush i got you in here
well there we go camp mograph yep yup
there's me way in the background right
there
james blake really ej yeah
matthias yeah beeples back here we got
beeple we got uh
um
freakin ash
yeah ash thorpe
yeah that was a good day
um this was a photo that we took when we
were all one wheeling together
we did this one i just did a little 2d
conversion
that looks like a tilt shift like it
looks
like it almost sucks like a like a
figurine like they don't look real at
all like they look like little action
figures i know
it's the scale i think i was like dude i
gotta do something like that
uh in 3d i think that this scale really
works out where it's like a bunch of a
bunch of things together
um that's cool i did a little 2d to 3d
conversion on this
uh render i did a while back this was
like early stream this might have been
stream number who knows or even if it
was a stream but it was a while ago and
then i did my first like c4d
version so you can actually see like
it's not tearing the sides aren't
tearing since it's actually 48 different
rendered frames in c4d
yeah
you can actually see behind the
penguin's head and everything like all
the way around it's pretty sweet and the
lights in the back change it's tough to
see because like
i have reflection on the glass here
and also the the camera is not the best
camera but yeah all the reflections on
the background are shifting there's like
surface imperfections
uh on the bottom as well so yeah i'll be
sure to include those in the description
as well
that's dope yeah
and waiting for my scene to still
open up like it's
in my project i have like
three different levels built into it i
forgot how big it is so
actually
i can save the method man one as like i
could render that out later oh actually
it's opening up now because that's going
to say i can render it out later just
for us to add to the pack if you want
but
looks like
we are good to go
sweet
so i
have and man i don't think i worked
as cleanly as i usually do so bear with
me as i try to find out what goes with
what in this scene
so i think this is my
sequencer here
let me double click on this
but basically
like
especially for like renders and stuff
you only build out what the camera sees
right like you don't have to build out
like an entire city sometimes yeah and
so what i did if you if i float around
this scene here
you can see that this is everything that
i have in my my scene here like i have
some buildings in the background
that have this little
nightmare you would call that
and then method man himself he's not
even walking on the plane
but if i look through my camera view
like if i just play it through
this is the animation that we had did
and everything so i have him walk up
put his you know his foot up on the
ledge and then in after effects i
actually have like the method man lego
would come in the screen i like how you
do it batman and stuff like that yeah
and so yeah i mean everything
inside my composition here is lined up
to be exactly how i want it to be inside
the camera
which is another tip that i learned
from um
watching some industrial lighting magic
like matte painter stuff that i had in
the background like some or not
background and uh back in the day when i
used to think i wanted to be a matte
painter that was something that they
would often emphasize was the only stuff
that really matters is the stuff that's
in camera and so you do everything in
camera like they would make like a
physical map painting bring that into
after effects and then they would just
start like two and a half d stacking
stuff in there yeah and it's just like
only the stuff in camera is what really
matters and so that's kind of the
mindset that i stuck with you know
throughout all these years and you know
it's held up because it makes sense like
why build out an entire world when
you're gonna only see so much here and
so it makes total sense man that's a
huge one save yourself so much time
yeah and especially this is like pre
unreal engine days too right like it
really
helps um keep your your scene really
light so you're able to navigate and
work through it because if you if i
build out like a massive city i mean it
would just bog everything down a lot of
stuff we don't even see so
i'm gonna bring i have to bring hollow
plate into the scene
and restart
that's the only thing about unreal
engine that gets me every time it's like
i try to make sure that i have all my
plugins at the beginning yep you know
turned on and then restart because like
restarting sometimes could just be a
pain so
what uh what rig are you on what um
what's your cpu your gpu setup
i'm using the threadripper 3 the
64 core one nice um
and then for the gpu i'm still back in
the well not still in ages but i have a
2080 ti which at this point is kind of
old but
it still holds up you know and then um
i have like 128 gigs worth of ram in
there as well so heck yeah yeah it's a
it's a pretty decent system you know i
just need to get maybe like a 40 90 or
something in there to kind of round it
out
absolutely man i i went the longest time
on my 2080. um probably a year and a
half ago is when i first upgraded um
right
so that like that thing carried me far
right right
um
john malcolm's wondering if you know the
artist mike thompson
if i know mike thompson do you know of
mike thompson by chance
um if i seen his stuff it might ring a
bell like i'm terrible at names so i'm
pretty sure i do but it's one of those
things right like
if i seen it i'd probably like oh okay
yeah totally
why what's up what's up good um what's
up with mr thompson well i think he's
saying that you guys are kind of running
in similar circles
so it might
you guys might uh might have crossed
paths at some point he was just
wondering
yeah i mean this
is possible
i mean this community is
as you know is so small you know so
everybody seems to know everybody it's
some type of capacity
all right so i got my
method main scene
in here let me see what it looks like in
my looking glass
oof
there's not
i'd have to do some some work to it
because the scaling of it
i don't know how you would um
how how would you match
the looking glass volume to your camera
do you parent it or something
um possibly but i think like if you're
looking at my blue box it's extremely
large compared to
what the size of my character is so
maybe if i change the scaling down
yeah i think you want to get that white
ring
or that white bracket to kind of just be
a touch larger than your character
yeah so i think that might have been my
issue there because he looked like an
aunt compared to like everything behind
him so oh for sure
let me see
let me try it now
there you go that's a lot better so yeah
the scaling of it
was the issue there so now it's just all
about
camera positioning
how do you change the depth of field if
you scroll down on the
holo play capture
you should see
the post process drop down and then
there's an override depth of field
checkbox that you hit
okay so
okay okay override depth of field
yeah and then the first thing i'll do is
i'll hit my draw debug
focus plane and i'll i'll crank the
first depth of field adjust setting so
that it it fits where i want it and then
from there
if you set your aperture depth of field
strength to just like one
you'll see it'll kind of take care of
that like aliasing that happens in the
background
so what do you set your aperture depth
of field to the strength i set it to one
and then um you go up
to make it uh to decrease the intensity
and you go down to increase the
intensity i think is how it works
alright this
okay yeah that's working i think i need
to
maybe pull the camera in a little bit
closer
there we go so i'm gonna turn off my
draw debug
and that actually looks
pretty cool i'm getting
some aliasing in the background it looks
like yeah work your uh
depth of field strength
so you can get that to like
one
and drop it lower i think will make it
more intense
okay so when i drop it to one
everything gets really blurry but if i
bring it up to like 50 everything gets
sharper oh yeah yeah so go go to like
five or something because i think at 10
it basically turns off at 10 i think but
it could be because your scene goes
pretty deep you know so
okay there we go so i'm gonna try seven
and i'll hold this up to the camera and
see it let's see
oh that's sick
yeah so i mean i can actually see
in person the details in his face like
it's really really clear
because i did like a feather scan a
message man in there so i have like all
his real details and everything of his
face in there that's awesome
so yeah it holds up pretty well i know
my ring light just kind of reflecting
off it but
you get the idea yeah
yeah those results look pretty good i
mean i'll make a quilt of this after the
stream and
you know anybody that has a looking
glass they could check that out as well
absolutely
um
i think if i were to start something
from here it would be like a whole deal
um
so
i'm thinking maybe we should call it and
then if people have questions for you
y'all drop some questions for wimbush
here
in the chat or if you have any questions
whatsoever we'll take
we'll take some time to answer your
questions maybe like
10 minutes or so
and yeah let me go for it yeah and then
uh winbush will be on his way and i will
do the weekly challenge
review
as we usually do um
awesome yeah
yeah
yeah let me
put my laptop uber
let's see guys any questions
from mr wimbush here
[Music]
nab
it's just too too close to the wedding
so for for those of you guys
who don't know and this kind of relates
here i'm getting married next weekend so
there will not be
a stream probably for
i think i'm going to be taking up almost
a month off
so this will be the last one for
at least three weeks um so i will miss
you all
and uh i will also be enjoying a
honeymoon too so
i'll be back that's awesome man some
nice r d some take some time off some r
r r r yeah yeah very excited for that
man um
that'd be cool uh if you guys have
questions for wimbush if you at just at
punisher me here in the chat that way i
can see it in orange and then i'll i'll
be able to
i'll be able to uh relay let's see
wimbush have you used the new vhf mesh
displacement any tips or documentation
you can what what is vhf displacement is
that the
the one by uh
no i'm thinking of the edo's
montreal stuff
you don't need to eat as much or that's
the vdb stuff yeah
um
totally wasn't the question they were
asking but have you used it
which one uh the idos um ab thing or
yeah i actually did the first tutorial
on it i was working with the developer
so if you get to my youtube channel i go
step by step on
how to install it and then how to bring
in
several types of vdb so a static vdb
like for clouds um i'll show you how to
bring in an animated vdb um we use an
example from embergen they have like
this little loopable tornado i'll show
you how to bring that in and then just
show you how to bring in an explosion so
like if you use ambergen or any vdv
packs or anything with explosions i'll
show you how to set that up as well
because
it does get kind of tricky because it is
a plug-in you know it's not officially
made by epic games and so the developer
has been working solely on it and um
he only got it to work well at least for
the explosion it only works with the
path tracing right so it doesn't work in
real time you have to render it out with
the power tracer so there's some
trickery there but it's on its way like
he's definitely been banging at it and
making some really cool stuff there
heck yeah that's awesome i love it man
you put out tutorials so fast you are on
it that's great
i try to be men
i try to be for those of you who
want to follow wimbush i got all of this
stuff uh in the description at least you
you sorry at least your youtube channel
i'm not to update it here with the with
the twitter
um
and instagram but you'll see it it's
linked right on the bottom of the screen
there
um
let's see all right let's go through
some of these questions if you see
anyone bush go for it
um
yeah get checked here but that measure
thing i didn't um
not even sure what that is same
uh mark
so you say you have some depth issues
with the iphone portrait photos on the
glass have i run into that or have any
suggestions yeah i think the closer
i am
like there was that one of my face
it almost looked like a flat card
that one is i think it was because i was
too close to the camera i think it needs
a little bit of distance on it
um
so i would say a little bit of distance
would probably help you out and you
could try experimenting with the like
wide angle lens or
um
like the longer lens on your phone if
you have the ability to
yeah
i'm trying to look um i'm trying to
understand this question that came up
this is i'm not sure if it is familiar
for you
it's by leonard he was asking what is
your experience on live animation
like you showed in the beginning what
influences the frame rate
do you know what he's speaking up there
or
no live animation
oh previewing the animation in the
looking glass talking about frame rate
is there a way to increase the
not yet um that's i forget brown was
telling us it was something that the way
that unreal engine 5 works at the moment
so i know they're working on the plug-in
for that because then when four
like especially if you go to any of my
tutorials like i was running
um a third person game in unreal live
theater looking glass using the xbox
controller and everything held up and so
i think it's just the way that the
coding you know how different it is in
five it might just take them a second or
two to you know get their the plug-in
compiled to work you know with um with
better frame rates but for now
it just looks um it's kind of
stop-motiony right but i mean you can
always just render it out make it into a
coil and then bring it in that way you
should be fine yeah yeah it's more for
just like a quick preview of what of
what your frame actually looks like
um and then you can just hop back into
your scene
adjust your lighting and stuff and then
run it again to see what it looks like
so yeah they're still working on on that
just just because of you know unreal
five literally just came out and i think
the
the
the looking glass plug-in came out on
thursday for unreal five so it's like
brand new
yeah just literally both things just
literally came out so i noticed this
with a lot of plug-ins like they're
still trying to
figure five out and how to implement
their plugins from four into five so
it's just gonna be one of those growing
pain things right like everything is
brand new so it's just gonna take
developers a little time to
you know get their stuff acclimated for
ue5
absolutely um we got uh mdk one of our
moderators here he's asking you what do
you think of the steam deck
i want one
yeah 100 especially because i'm starting
to see some home brew stuff come up for
it which that's my weight host like i
said i love technology and tinkering and
taking stuff apart so
when i saw the steam deck initially by
valve and they had that video of them
taking it apart i'm just like
i'm all in so i was just waiting for
maybe the second batch i didn't want to
get the first batch just in case you
know anything was botched or anything
but just seeing some of the reviews on
youtube it looks pretty legit and so i
saw a video last night where they put a
dreamcast emulator
on the sting deck so dreamcast that's my
favorite system of all time so i'm just
like yeah i'm all in i got to get one
though heck yeah i remember like on the
psp i had it all hacked out i was
playing i was playing like uh
super smash bros i was playing mario
kart on the psp
and i loved that whole like it wasn't
just what you saw but yeah it goes deep
you know and i love that so if the steam
deck is trying to do that then that that
sounds pretty sweet
yeah i think like it's not official um
like they're not like legally i don't
think they could say like hey you know
break this thing apart at home brew it
and put emulators and stuff on there but
they're not leaning against it you know
like they know
they even showed how you could install
windows 10 on there if you really wanted
to so
that's
absurd let's see who else we got
um
so rick markley is asking
have you found a way to cut between
multiple
hollow cams
um um
like they they have multiple
um looking glasses hooked up to it up to
their one system
i don't know trying to understand
trying to understand that question
rick if you want to put down a little
bit more uh info for us
uh let's see
ah okay soto could you each recommend a
good movie what is uh
i don't know recent recent movie or show
that you've been enjoying right now
um really enjoyed well show wise archive
81 on netflix um even though they just
said season two wasn't coming i thought
season one was really great
so um yeah i really like that one and
then movie-wise
i'm trying to think last movie we saw
was sonic 2 actually last weekend my
daughter and i went to see it which i
thought was really good so
oh man okay i heard the sonic movies
were like
not bad they're good yeah no they're
they're they're really good especially
for a gaming franchise it's like they
finally were able to get
no you know whenever they use gaming ips
they usually screw it up
yeah yeah i feel like the sonic
storyline and lore is um
so like all over the place that they
were able to actually make a script work
in live-action format so yeah i would
suggest watching the first one if you
haven't seen any of them yet and just
watching the sequence heck yeah all
right that's what i heard that's what
griffin from corridor told me he was
like dude
sonic movies i was like i never thought
i would be hearing this right now that's
sonic you gotta watch the sonic movies
okay i'm i'm down for jim carrey is he
in the second one too yeah yeah he's in
both of them actually they said sonic 2
was his highest gruesome movie of all
time what
yeah like it beat out all his classics
you know like the mask and ace ventura
and all that stuff like it doesn't hurt
a candle like sonic 2 just did in the
box office so
goodness i guess
wow that's crazy
geez yeah i mean it's good especially
like jim you know you haven't seen him
in a while well before sonic won yeah he
definitely has a good performance in
there that's great i know he kind of
like went off
i don't know i've seen some videos of
him going off the rocker i don't know
what was going on there but
yeah i mean he even said well before it
became a hit right like doing a red
carpet he said this is probably his last
acting role
but
i mean that was before he saw what the
box office was gonna do so
i pretty sure he's going to come back
for like a sonic 3.
dang
that's crazy yeah
um
last good
thing i've seen uh
i was thinking about this yesterday
we're watching barry right now it's
pretty good um
but
uh what is it called white lotus
that show blew me away
uh it's like a
intense
drama kind of funny at a
hawaiian hotel about all the people
staying at the hotel just how
bad people
all a bunch of bad people in one place
and you're following all these different
people and they like
converge it's pretty nuts
um
i watch moon night that was okay
uh i haven't seen it yet i was waiting
well i guess the last episode just aired
right that's kind of waiting for the
whole season so i could just kind of
binge it okay i got you i think i need
like two more to go but
let's see what else
okay so
um you're saying can you cut between
different like
looking glass um volumes or looking
glass cameras in unreal i don't know i
don't think so
um
no it's nothing that i've experimented
with but you know inside your sequencer
how you could have your your kama cut
tracks i wonder if you have
um because you get edit you know inside
of unreal with different cameras and
stuff like that because it the sequencer
is essentially like a non-linear editor
so i'm wondering
if you um
you take your hollow plate inside your
sequencer and if you have several homes
set up i wonder if you just edit it like
you would a video and just like trim
down
you know your um your camera inside the
sequencer and just stack them in there i
mean it's definitely worth trying out
like i'm just thinking outside the box i
don't know if it's gonna work but
i guess that would be the way that i
would try it you know i could see that
for sure
yeah
you have to let us know make sure you
come back in the comments after you try
it out yeah absolutely
yeah
do you know of a cheaper option for
hollow displays compared to the looking
glass
honestly i had i do not i like the
looking glass to me seems like the only
the only one that i know of but
yeah don't think there's another
looking glass type box
as far as i'm saying they're like the
only one who's doing this right now i
think in terms of like
accessibility
um
i know that their their 8k
one is like really expensive that's for
definitely for companies but the smaller
one that you guys are seeing here i
think that's the cheapest that's
certainly the cheapest one they have and
i don't know of any other company who's
doing anything like this so
yeah i mean there's holographic displays
out there um
there's a company that did the do you
remember the red phone from back in the
day yeah
the hydro phone yeah so that was like a
holographic phone right so
um that company releases some stuff and
then um
the company that um kenza is actually
working with they they have like all the
nft gallery shows and stuff i'm not sure
how they do it but they convert like
regular tvs into
holographic displays um it's not like a
box like the looking glass but you know
if you want it
yeah i don't know if kenza wants to drop
a link in there i'm not sure what i
think it's called like the gallery or
something like that i'm not even sure if
it's for sale but i'm just throwing
options out there but consumer wise yeah
i think looking glass might be
might be your butt yeah
um
so windbush here before i let you go man
is there anything that
you want to talk about anything you're
working on next that you can talk about
get people amped about
um
yeah i guess that that is that
that is the question there's no more i i
tend to talk a lot as i'm doing right
now so i'll let you take it from here
yeah no i mean again appreciate you
having me on the live stream if you guys
could you know follow me on my youtube
channel youtube.com jonathanwinbush i
did recently receive the epic mega grant
and so what epic is doing they are
funding me and making a beginner's
course for unreal engine 5 which i'm
going to release absolutely free through
my youtube channel so that's going to be
the only way that you're going to have
access to it so just like my previous
course i'm planning on doing about 10
hours worth of content taking
an absolute new from beginner that never
opened up unreal engine 5 before take
you through the steps of how to you know
start up your first scene get familiar
with the navigation controls and just
really take the baby steps that you
might need to get from a to z instead of
like if you go to a lot of channels now
right like it's not really outlined out
to help people learn you know unreal
from the first steps to the last steps
like it's usually just random tutorials
right so i like to streamline it and so
that people they would have you know
like chapter one chapter two chapter
three and they know exactly where they
are in case they need to go back and
pick up any tips anywhere in the past
there so look for that on my youtube
channel coming soon i'll probably be
done with that in like a month or two
heck yeah so yeah big shout out to epic
for funding that project because that
was that was the biggest thing for me
right like my last course it was 240 i
think but
not everybody has 240 dollars you know
especially coming out of the pandemic
and
people in other countries where 250
bucks might be their month income right
so you know i explained that to epic
they were 100 on board they funded the
whole project and they were like you
know put out a course for free and that
everybody learned unreal so that's my my
next big project that i'm currently
working on now that's great dude i can't
wait yeah i cannot wait i feel like
william foshe he's popping off with his
stuff
um so it'll be it'll be cool to have
someone
step up and like
take something from start to finish
because you all right no one's really
doing that on youtube not that i know of
um yeah
i mean there's a few out there but they
might be like our worth of content but
like i'm going all in just like my last
course like you're gonna know unreal by
the time you finish this thing like
there's no questions about how to do
stuff so good because i need that yeah
i'll tell you right now
yeah oh man
dude thank you so much for joining us
man i'll let you get about your day um
but i look forward to hanging out with
you more i hope to see you at camp later
this year
um
yeah man definitely um
yeah we gotta hang up before that though
i mean really really only an hour away
so yeah i have to get a hike or
something you know
let's get a hike let's bring some water
um
do it safe yeah
not that door not heat wave right like
no
no all good on that thanks man i
appreciate you very much thank you
wimbush i'll catch you soon man all
right thank you again appreciate it man
yeah peace out
all right everybody
uh thank you guys for for hanging with
us that was really cool um thanks to
wimbush for hopping in with us and
creating some stuff in unreal
we'll have those
looking glass files uploaded here a
little bit later
after i get myself a pizza
gotta get that after stream pizza
but before i close it out guys we gotta
do
the weekly challenge winners
all right so
uh let's just let's just jump into it
shall we
[Music]
all righty
let me get this full screen
and see what we're doing here
all right
so the theme this week
was
swamp
so
starting with uh our first let me hold
on let me pop this out real quick
get this over here
all right well whatever this this will
be fine our first winner for the swamp
challenge looks to be
3d gala
with
a short film that they put together
which i thought was very nice
lurking through the swamps
very nicely uh
nicely shot nicely lit
i wonder if is this blender or unreal
engine i am unsure but wait a second
what is that
oh my god
the flashlight that is that is some
creepiness
very very good
very good it was edited well
shot well cut well um
it was lit well
and it was just darn creepy
the only thing
that bugs me was as soon as the
flashlight comes up and shines on the
creature
and turns away
i knew what was coming i knew what was
coming
so i wonder if there's like an easier
maybe like the flashlight
uh loses batteries it starts starts
hitting it or something and then shines
it up again i just don't know why the
person turned around so
that's a nitpick for sure
but 3d gala congrats to you you got the
challenge winner roll this week hang on
to it you're doing well next up
we have ham sog
with this beautiful piece my goodness
perfectly rendered
perfectly lit perfectly placed the
composition is off the charts your eye
is drawn to the battle down below in the
swamp
because of the torches it's the
brightest part of the image the only
gripe i have i just wish that the
foreground on the left was lit a little
bit it needs to be separated from the
background i feel like they blend into
each other just a touch
touch too much
maybe an edge light on that character
maybe a different
color temperature perhaps on that
character maybe some moonlight hitting
them or something just a little
something to bring them towards the
camera and pull them out from that
background
um
but
i mean everything here is just firing on
all cylinders so hamstock
congratulations for winning the
challenge winner roll
this week you all get
15 points
to the roll on the discord server
and y'all you all are leveling up we got
some people who have leveled up uh which
is really cool you all got those
different uh those tier badges
which we put out like probably probably
a month or two ago and it's it's a
really cool little feature we're very
proud of it next up
who do we got uh edward
yeah
edward oh not edward
hold on now
it's so hard to read what is it
obliviart
bam beautiful
the lighting and the color on this is
off the charts you also
hand sculpted this character which is so
freaking cool
um bonus points to y'all for hand
sculpting stuff here
in this week
i love your atmospheric fog
i love your lighting and your colors
congratulations obliviard for that
challenge winner roll
is looking beautiful all right now we
got edward let's see what's up
this one yes this one
it's super creepy it's very well done
it's well composed it's well lit
um it's very well rendered it looks
pretty darn photo real i love the uh
like the
it's not a buoy it's not a life raft um
it's the life ring
the lifesaver whatever
on the right i think it's a really nice
touch um i love the fact that you have
your atmosphere built in like this i
think that looks great and it's able to
actually uh
give you some depth it separates the
different layers going off into the
background so it makes it seem larger
and it's very creepy you're about to
have this encounter with this zombie
thing
uh so it has an emotional element to it
as well so congrats edward on that one
and finally
we got ya
cgmd sculpting a custom character
for this challenge for this week
i love the lighting you got a nice
flashlight on the top of this guy
the moonlight as a rim light on the
right side is very well done
and it illuminates the fog in the
atmosphere into the background which is
great you're also doing a really cool
trick too where
you're using the fog on the bottom
kind of on the horizon line at the top
of the lake
to silhouette
the character to bring them out from the
background
so that's a really good way to do it
you're crushing it here y'all cgmd
congratulations to you and the rest
of the challenge winners this week but
that is not all as you guys know we got
some honorable mentions to get into
um who do we got
one trose
fundrose all right you got a nice little
frog scene i just thought this was
really nice
it's well rendered it's well lit your
color correction looks really really
nice
um it's just a solid scene i dig it
all right next up we got ballsy
yes
yes
so
this one here
is
really cool i feel like you have the
swamp thing
on the tv i feel like the swamp thing
needs to be on the poster in front of
you because that's where my eye goes to
first is to that poster
so you're i get what you're doing of
course you're taking swamp in a
different different direction but it's
totally
totally works
um i just have to hunt for it so i need
i feel like it should be on that poster
but great job here laying out this room
it's very well detailed it's well
thought out it's well lit so you should
be very very very very proud of this one
uh five points to all of the honorable
mentions
as well
uh next up we got casual night
with a little short film just two shots
but i thought the atmosphere the
lighting was there you did a great
especially the shot my goodness that is
beautiful
absolutely beautiful
the thing that bugs me a little bit is
the aspect ratio i you know you never
really see a square aspect ratio
um
you're going for a very filmic
movie like kind of lighting it's very
dramatic i would love to see
a filmic aspect ratio so 16 9 at least
or 1 to 235 for ultra widescreen i think
that'll make it feel really nice
um that would be my suggestion to you uh
the
yeah it's well done good camera work
good atmosphere good lighting
it's just the rocks on the left they
feel a little low res everything else
feels really really nice
next up we got eloy
i love the lighting i love the color on
this
it feels very unique
it's framed nicely it has a very nice
flow
to the composition it flows
bottom left
up to mid right back to top left and
then it swoops back over it's a nice s
curve
um and the bio luminescent swamp is a
really cool idea so you should be proud
gray on gray
is next
beautifully lit
beautifully composed
um
it looks extremely photoreal
i think my only gripe with this one oh i
will say too
really good job on the color correction
you have the light coming down on top of
the house and the right side of frame
is darkened up just enough to really
kind of spot like that house and of
course
you're justifying it by the opening in
the trees just above this house
my only gripe is
the hdri or the sky that you're using is
just white
to me
and i would love to see a bit more
clouds even a sunset in the background
like it's foggy and stormy in the
foreground but in the background you
have uh
some different kind of
some god rays perhaps something
different in the background
yeah maybe some birds or something it
just needs it needs a little bit some of
something um maybe someone
in a boat with a lantern pulling up to
their house with a dock with some
lanterns uh
yeah it just needed something a little
bit more but i think your render skills
are very nice here
color correction is very nice
uh jack bowman
got you next this one's super cool
dig the composition i dig the idea
um the only thing that threw me was the
shading on or rather the shader on this
giant
it just felt a little too waxy too much
like default material
um i think you probably could have
pushed the tones a little bit more maybe
a bit more contrast or something but i
really liked what you were going for i
think it was i like your god rays the
color is nice the idea is nice so
congrats to you
uh next up is
excel styler
something uh
beautiful piece really good idea
good color good composition good emotion
solid idea the lighting is really nice
subsurface might be a little intense
they look a little gummy
the one that threw me on this was the
face
um
it's a real hard thing to do
you did your best
it just feels a little
too
fake
too much like a toy maybe
um
that's a hard one i to be honest i've
never done it so i can't say too much
about it
other than it just throws me a little
bit
but you should be very proud of this it
looks beautiful you lit it perfectly you
colored it perfectly you framed it the
idea is awesome so thumbs up to you uh
louis is next for honorable mention
good god this would have won if it was a
swamp
it just wasn't a swamp
it's a forest with a brook
uh and a nice little stream
yeah this is 10 out of 10. it just
doesn't follow the prompt
um
it's beautiful
absolutely beautiful your color your
lighting your render
quality your composition
i want to be here right now with a pizza
next up
mod of ramesh
yeah
master sword trials
in breath of the wild that's what this
reminds me of
you did a really good job here with your
lighting and your atmosphere
i think it's super solid i love your
colors too great scene great character
really good stuff
um
what i would have done uh
maybe moved your character over to the
left a little bit more made them a bit
bigger
maybe punched in
with a different
you know what this is it's just a good
piece
it's just a really good piece
i don't really know what there is to say
about maybe take your character to the
left a little bit more
either put them more in of a silhouette
or hit them with a little spotlight
but i like the darker tones you're going
with on that character
maybe change their shirt colors so
they're more silhouetted
but
anyway this is a cool piece i really dig
it i like your atmosphere and i like the
style it has has some good style points
to it m design is next
this is another cool one like i felt
like i could be here
i really like your silhouettes
i think you maybe could use a touch more
fog on this one
to kind of um
the trees blend into each other just a
little bit too much
i feel like you could separate them from
each other with a little bit more fog
but i love this world that you put
together it's frog
frog outpost
in the swamp you got the bubbles in
there and everything too
i think it's super cool
metatrox is next same deal yeah you
gotta you got characters in this you got
a little uh
little story going on
they're going
fishing or hunting for fireflies or
something i love your blue green color i
think you could have used a little bit
more contrast on this
some darker blacks would have been nice
to see
um
and maybe a touch more
fog to bring them out i don't know what
they're being lit by
i would work on your lighting on your
subject because i don't know where that
light is coming from
it looks like a lantern on the
front of the boat but i don't see a
lantern
they could have used an edge light
perhaps just to bring them out a little
bit more
and they almost look untextured because
they're like the same texture as the
sail
um i think they could have just been
separated from the background a touch
more with lighting with some fog
but otherwise
i dig your scene
andy wren
is next
yeah i'm a sucker for the atmosphere man
and you're crushing it here
uh if rendered at a super high
resolution looks beautiful your fog is
perfect
i want to be in this world
the one the thing that threw me on this
one was
the pose
of this character i felt like the pose
is a little static
um
it could have used something a bit more
dynamic perhaps
maybe a little creepier maybe it's it's
hunched over
um
it's pretty darn terrifying it just
feels a little too static and too stiff
for me in that pose
but your atmosphere is killer and i love
that like yellow orange
glow i think that's really nice too
it draws the eye for sure i think it's
missing
a little something though i don't know
what
because it's like you either have the
glow or you don't and if you don't i
feel like everything would blend in with
it though i like the color i feel like
it just needs a little bit more of it
somewhere around the scene
i'm not sure where but
maybe it could be some sort of light
that's reflecting off of the swamp water
perhaps
yeah i don't know
but
it's the
it's the pose it's the pose that gets me
otherwise hey congrats i mean it's an
honorable mention so i wanted to shout
you out for that man uh phil is next
this is a great idea
this is a really good idea
um
it's another one though that i feel like
could use a little bit
more
uh work on the lighting
to pull
the foreground character out from the
background i think in motion this would
totally be fine
um
otherwise
some sort of edge light some sort of rim
light on this car
um
the background
could
go off into maybe a bit more darkness
it's kind of just like a washed out
green right now
um what
else maybe the blue could be a touch
brighter
i think i think it's just
what you i feel okay i think what you
need is um
your subject to just be to have more
contrast
that way it pops out
a little bit more from the frame and
your focus is right on it you're spot on
with the blue
you got the opposite color going there
so that's nice or not opposite i guess
it would be uh secondary
i'm making stuff up at this point
who else we got pranav
ah this one almost won this one came
close
your lighting is incredible
uh the render is really really nice
i think the tentacles need a little
something they need a bit more goo
or they need to be smoothed out a little
bit more like i can almost see your
spline like it's
a little jagged
um
but yeah this one this one came really
close to winning so you should
definitely take that to heart
congratulations
soulnate we got another one here um this
one's this one is nice
um i think what gets me here like good
job with the atmosphere and everything
with the lighting what gets me here is
the colors it feels like a little too
dreamy too soft for me personally of
course this is just coming from me
um
and your water almost looks red i think
it is red i'm colorblind but it looks
red to me so it feels
it feels like i don't want to be here i
do not want to be that dude
in that boat um i would i just want to
go home
you got some blue on the top right uh
that's a tough one
that's a tough one
yeah kind of
it's i think this one's just the color
for me
maybe it's just because i'm colorblind
but who knows
um but i dig your composition
i dig the lighting and i dig the
atmosphere of course
noodle chan
this one
almost won
this was a very very very difficult
um
decision
it's beautiful like i don't i don't
really know if i have too much
too many notes on this
but
it is beautiful
your atmosphere is spot on the character
work is great the design is really good
yeah this is like
ah i so wanted there to be six winners
on this one
because this would have been it it was a
very difficult decision i had to open it
up to some of the other moderators and
get their opinion on it it was just too
darn close for me
um good stuff
good stuff noodle
uh how many more do we have
two two three more clive we got you next
here buddy
um this one's awesome good uh good
composition good framing
good atmosphere
good lighting
it just feels a little empty to me i
think it needs uh
some more foliage
some more imperfections in the water
you have a line of shrubs just going
from the right to left it needs more it
definitely needs more
same for your background
it just looks like it it needs some
scattered
foliage for sure i think
i think that would have done it for me
it needs some droopy
hanging stuff from the tie fighter
definitely needs that
so
that would be the thing
under is
next great scene great idea
i think the lighting on this one is
tough also
the character looks a bit video gamey to
me
um
[Music]
yeah i think it's the lighting the
character blends into the ground a lot
your colors are cool i dig your colors
but i think you could have popped out
the characters a little bit more with
your lighting i would i would go back
and try that
but i dig your idea
and i dig your camera angle i dig your
colors
good stuff
wet dragon killer that is the last
honorable mention
very cool scene here your composition
and your lighting that's what does it
for me the reflection off of the swamp
water
you got your rain i feel it it's
visceral
it's a really nice piece
very very nice piece cool idea as well
that is it y'all that is it
there's a lot of honorable mentions to
get through but we did it congrats to
the winners congrats to the honorable
mentions
um
we got another weekly challenge popping
off on the discord server as always the
link is in the description
if you guys
want to
mess around with this looking glass i
got you 40 bucks off with a link in the
description as well it's really really
fun to mess with i can't wait i'm so
glad that like
i was able to get into this and finally
get it going because i've had it for a
while
and i've been so busy i finally was able
i've wanted to do this stream for a long
time i wanted to do
a uh collab stream with wimbush and this
was the perfect idea because we both
have them uh
and it's it's so much fun to see what
you can do with this thing
so
check out the link in the description if
you guys want to pick one up for
yourself 40 bucks off for you um
and
they also have discord community too
where you can post all your stuff
uh all your files you can download other
artists files too
um i know i'll be posting up my stuff
here link to this video so if you're
watching after the fact it'll probably
be there
for those of you watching live you have
to wait a little bit i gotta get myself
some food um
but yeah that's about it guys thank you
so much i will hang out for the next
five minutes with y'all and take any
questions you guys might have
i really appreciate you guys hanging out
to the end with me
that was a fun one i can't wait to keep
creating more stuff for this thing
it's been a blast
arms thank you
thank you for the kind words thanks for
hanging out
rousseau what's the name of the
background music it's uh stream beats
right sodo
yeah i'm pretty sure it's stream beats
um so you can just check their stuff on
spotify i think they got a lot of good
stuff
i'll see you later
styles later later
kenza i'm glad you were able to join
that's super cool
i will enjoy that pizza some of the best
pizza i've ever had and thank you for
the wedding uh
kind words on the wedding we're very
excited for that it's gonna be sweet
let's see yes i have some nice upcoming
days and weeks
that is for sure
i'm very excited
very excited we'll take a good break
want a little honeymoon
come back i'll be refreshed and ready to
go
let's see any of the questions that you
guys might have
arturo thanks for stopping by i
appreciate you man
yeah arturo's awesome he's the second my
second patron ever
it's pretty crazy
yeah and he also he also got a job
recently
very recently at the looking glass so it
was nuts how that worked out freaking
crazy
ah
well if you guys don't have any
questions i might have to bounce because
i'm getting a little hungry
i think i export these uh
these files too for y'all
well then
looks like i'm gonna call it
thank you guys cheers to you
i will see you
in probably one month from now
maybe three weeks maybe three weeks
but definitely a month from now
so uh hang in there have fun
go to winbush's channel watch his stuff
pick up a looking glass make some stuff
for it uh and i will see you guys in
three
to four
weeks all right
so i'll miss you you guys have a good
one
and i'll catch you soon
have fun
keep creative
peace out y'all later
[Music]
two
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you